thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
my check my check
the Lord's return the Lord's returns
roll call Round what's up Lydia Master
what's going on Gerald Mackey oh gee I
see with the videos Lloyd Metroid what's
going on let me know how my levels are
found let me know super duper man
super duper man 76-91 let's go all right
yeah [ __ ] okay okay Phil he feels away
about the leaks
not gonna put the name of the title
because I'm not I don't want that rock
star federally smoke
and I'm Keith what's going on he don't
like the five hours of Old Man dad jokes
a fake laughter let's go
but you here though and I like that you
rocking with us no doubt Sith Lord
what's going on you already know arcade
42 47 what's up Isaac Gentry what's up
Andre Drummond what's going on yeah it
leaks is crazy big cloud what's up bro I
talk to you in a minute what's going on
brother hope everything is good just rgt
in your movement the turf what's going
on gorilla one what's up hi Craig Hall
again the holies in the building salute
death chat what up what up what's going
on what's right thank you for the
soundtrack yeah man attic talk to the
people it's a very intense show we got
the three four three departures it's a
huge game week quote unquote
TGs you know what's funny that we have
so much stuff to talk about we had we we
could only put TGs in the time yeah we
couldn't put anything else
I want to call it Duty stuff hat like
it's so much
dip down in the business Sinister what's
up I know we gotta do trial oh whiskey
brows Phil mops of the building proud to
feel Brooklyn let's go okay I get
excited when I see the town in there you
already know
I get excited when I don't see it
live Supremacy yeah yeah yeah we it's a
leak topic but we we ain't putting that
title name in the title
um jefftrap what's up welcome to the
king king Welcome To The King and them
podcast that's what you gotta call it
King and them
that chat what up man that was funny uh
but man I can't wait to that's his name
like soft get it right tahitris what is
me them leaks though yeah them leaks
out here get your forces right you know
what I'm saying it's it's looking
crazy the turf is going on
so yeah man we're gonna go get the king
you know what I'm saying we're gonna get
dipped down demons Young Gun is up in
here
I feel like ax what's up you better
hurry up and pull out king Marshall yeah
King might show up get the DC up so
we're gonna be oh what's going on
hustling motivate you already know you
got enough issues yeah
so yeah we'll be back about to get up in
here but mess things up so we gotta mute
that into that you hear about the kid
called and said okay no doubt all right
we'll see y'all in a minute
they're pretty much saying he needs to
just go ahead and bend the knees yeah
they went to me earlier they say try to
raid y'all on YouTube yeah YouTube Red
with the rating man like I literally
have to like unlock like give you the
keys yeah to let you rape people be
cable and Gabe all week
Where Brooklyn Where Brooklyn stay in
the town let's go anyway I gotta go back
he's gonna mess this up
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
using these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless and people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be using
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but a man talk
social or my city but I'm still
bi-coaster
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with a game
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
and we are live iron Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it
so we got that Focus line y'all this is
that standard that's what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing this focus on Deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta Adeline so you don't get the
Jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know Cog
love is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advancedg.com use code iron Lord on a
checkout this is something I use all the
time got to support Advanced EG great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration in line for those
who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lower
Cognito here iron Lord podcast peace
[Music]
nothing much
[Music]
I'ma just chill and watch them in these
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
vendor I gotta be Neato I know it's my
destiny work to carnido who cares if you
fly if you stealing mosquito you swear
you ain't something but really be Stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but I got bad news even if you
really was that joke King David still be
the king of the statue sister juvenile
I've been cursed with a curse to be
Musical and if you hate it we'll meet in
The Crucible other than nothing it's
cool and it's beautiful we let you know
that your dreams are pursuable whatever
you want to do then it's doable if you
got work on a Sunday it's suitable cause
you can listen to this in your cubicle
on the Lord today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
we not doing that job everybody
we had guests
and we are live with the hot bikes bike
checks and all that here you hear you
and welcome to the island podcast LLC
also live on lordsofgaming.net episode
number 272. there's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the round table on
the Lord's date very excited about our
special guests and we've got three four
three departures
should I even say that name attic no no
leaks of a major game
if you if you have been scrolling
through Twitter today you will know what
leaks we are talking about very faucet
heavy leaks
[Laughter]
a lot of water is all over the place
Tokyo game show 2022 Nintendo Direct
plus octopath traveler 2 skipping Xbox
and Sony state of play to discuss so we
gonna get right into it oh somebody hit
the membership already
you know what I'm saying so I wanted I
want to introduce some up and coming
Lords who not only form a unique Trio in
the content creator space but creatively
find a way to synergize gaming the anime
world with pure entertainment vibes
introducing the created host of the dip
down games and anime YouTube channels
the Lords of hilarious horror streams
and Amber anime knowledge who always
find a way to talk that gaming live
live from Ohio and making their debut
into the realm of the Lords my gods Lord
Stevie Ray and Lord KP of dip down games
how we doing what's up man yo I've been
listening to you through some intros now
for a minute just waiting like man will
we ever get our shot to do something
like that I hear that intro like that
that was awesome man you know what's
funny I still ain't never hit an
insurance
I live vicariously through everyone
I think it's the best treatment
[Laughter]
thanks for having me thanks for having
me no doubt good to have you in the
round KP in the building you know what
I'm saying we're gonna have some fun
today a lot of fun topics first of all
quickly uh what have you boys been
playing Man start with Stevie Ray Lewis
oh man we've been really hankering down
on a lot of different horror games
whether it be like dead by daylight
Mortuary assistance
I got the demo I have the demo for steam
deck and oh my God
you got to do the embalming flu you
gotta really do it yeah you gotta really
do it man and boy they'd be jump scaring
you left and right that yo I I don't
been sleeping the same since man
what you playing man oh I'm I'm one of
those people I wanted them cauter
Maniacs
I'm a slave to the battle pass
yeah they got me in there I can't hear
you but I think your Zoom is muted just
make sure the zoom is yeah because it's
not coming through the zoom make sure
that we can see I think he turned it off
yeah so he didn't try talking down
this camera
keep talking yeah it doesn't switch
something good yes it sounds lower right
yeah go back to what you was doing then
go back okay but it doesn't go to him
when he's talking yeah okay
it might not do the switch he might have
to leave and come back yeah it's just
like his glitch I think you might just
uh his mic is hooked up to uh my
computer so his mic actually oh y'all up
in the same spot
oh he's right here
[Music]
dip down with the get down and I was
gonna say your joints look so Synergy
yo it's funny like what on the light
left side like I I assume uh it seems
like a his and her type of thing is that
what's going on or yeah
yeah he does come up as muted though in
Zoom I guess I think I think it's glitch
what you doing okay leave it come back I
just want to make sure okay yeah and
then come back unmuted I wanna I just
want to see a switch all right you good
song what happened someone he said my
Michael's wallet yeah you hear how loud
he is he went crazy
hello hello hello all right you know I
need let me play with your joysters
no this is what I'm subjected to weekly
you already know why we waiting for KP
to come back oh they ain't gonna come
back before we start off he's right in
the Next Room
talk to the people let's see what's good
y'all got me there we go there you go
yeah
I don't know if it's switched
but I know the mic I think it's because
they're on the same PC yeah
I've never encountered this before what
I'll do is I'll do a manual switch when
we get into the history when he talks
for a long enough for a long time
it's gonna be a disembodied voice
I'm a narrator
and you already know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those original Lords
of the realm here at the round table my
co-host with the cold Mouse my brother
from banana mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man Tick Tock
Lord
addicting yeah
I gave you what no no no no
a lot of tick tocks
it's gonna be like one of those things
where it's like that's not my name
I'm not responding to it you're taking
for somebody else take it from me
you in tune with the young boys
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
um I've been playing some uh actually
I've been playing Destiny this week uh I
got this
this little Pokemon
oh you guys can't see but it's Pokemon
uh Diamond brilliant Diamond nice so
I've been playing that a little bit Yeah
brilliant but the game is brilliant but
is it called brilliant diamond yeah
that's what it's called yes yes
definitely you know if you guys want to
uh see the unboxing of the year
that's that cool let's see the backflip
that bad flip it around you know what
I'm saying that's that no no okay that
look like it go right with little man
right yeah for real yeah and I think
they did that in conjunction with little
man but I gotta say if um if y'all never
had an elite controller oh go watch his
video because this video is from a
perspective of an individual that has
never had one yeah it was so insightful
I've never had the version two I had
like Smooth had one that he he got a new
controller and he sold me like one of
his old version ones but I think be a
lot of you man smooth you kind of you
kind of you kind of you kind of got one
over me man once I'm sitting there I got
to control it like I ain't even lying
man that thing fell apart remember
version version one was was a little the
rubber on the side kept coming off and
yes I told Lords get that Best Buy
protection plan
they give you a brand new one right you
know right now
you told me because I went there like
five times
like him again yeah
man you're gonna have to hit me up on
Twitter we're gonna have to get you on
here
man what you call the brother the the
light the Light Side
darker now real quick I got a shot cause
I've been messing up on merch and I
apologize for them so real quick someone
bought the slides like two weeks ago so
we got the unity shirts a week ago wow
somebody got a cup IOP cup snap
yeah I've been messing up so I apologize
we got to get these shout outs I know
the anonymous thing we're working on it
um somebody got the Pint glass Dominus
Maximus IOP hoodie today so Dominus
Maximus gotta put up the um
and we got that joint the IOP a lot of
stuff is coming out of that store yeah
yeah um you know because attic and I uh
is talking to Lord soft yeah
some stuff happening I was just gonna
say I do want to point out you know
anyone on here that's on the tick tock
you know uh you know we are on there
Iron Lord's podcast you know what's
funny is we have like three iron Lords
podcasts because I made one a long time
ago and then King made one but mine had
numbers in King didn't I'm like King I
mean I'm gonna need that officially man
I'm gonna need that info I don't I don't
want to be Iron Lords podcast two five
six six I need that I need that clean
got that early got that early so that's
it you've been rocking Destiny doing the
reviews and all that
it got quite oh yeah yeah
no I thought you were still talking I
thought you was talking to King because
he was talking no no no no no no I've
been uh doing the review stuff I have
been you know how people go already
message me addict you reviewing God of
War like dude calm down that's in
November like like relax no doubt no
doubt so really he's not reviewing yeah
and of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also
disastradamus the Lord of clarity and
Lord patreon of the iron bank my man
Lord Sovereign how we doing sir I'm
doing fantastic sir you're doing very
good you know heat dying down in New
York City it's a little cooler so I
enjoy that not sweating bullets uh
feeling a little better every single
week you know how you're improving
you're improved yeah doing good they're
doing good you know it's like I said
every single week I still have this
nagging cough that's annoying
um
these games though actually all that
Ubisoft talk last week or that
Assassin's Creed talk last week got me
back in the mood so I had to go back in
so I had to go but there's a couple of
believe it or not there are a couple of
Assassin Creed games that I have not had
uh that I started but fell off of
whatever one of them was Rogue
maybe like two three hours of Rogue and
then fell off because I was playing
Unity now mind you Unity at the time was
broken like broken but it was it was the
new Assassin's Creed it was it was the
new take on what the future of Assassins
right it was the co-op it was like the
the at the smoothness and the animations
they changed a lot of stuff where Rogue
was more kind of like the sequel to to
Black Flag which I loved but it was like
it was weird that they released both of
those at the same time so I didn't know
foreign so I picked it up super cheap on
on the steam deck and I'm playing it
it's high settings
High settings 60 FPS beautiful
definitely looks better than it did on
the 360.
yeah that was the issue yeah it was
crazy yeah so it's beautiful on the
steam deck and the story is good because
your number one fan has responded
you gotta read that wow you're playing
with your joystick five dollar Super
Chat Lord swabson Suave is someone else
thank you I love it I'm leaking
wow wow he or she is lit
if you haven't played Rogue it is cool
because it is it is an assassin
realizing that he Vibes more with the
Templar way of thinking and converting
to Templar and turning around and
hunting his own brothers so it's it's
very different uh take one I think you
just ruined the whole game you find that
out from the beginning
[Music]
I am talking dude as I say not as I do
hey bro
my intent is to go back to also play um
the heck is the other one that I didn't
finish
there's something else
Syndicate there you go Syndicate yeah I
love Syndicate did not finish it so I'm
gonna go back and play that as well
that's it no doubt no doubt and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
you squeezed his stomach
yo the prophet of Xbox
King of the statues we demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
Oh Be Love It Lord King how are we doing
sir
[Laughter]
today
uh better than Triple G I wish Triple G
woke up with a violence in his heart
yesterday
this is this dude this dude shout out to
boxing for trying to rob Canelo oh
um uh 113 115 I don't know what planet
you do
Kingdom yeah it was like Don the success
of Don King was sitting in there like
yeah cheater
um this dude waited to round 10 to mount
some type of offense oh I hate that and
I'm like okay I done gave y'all guys 200
um
200 I got three fights is 200 yeah yeah
Zone I want to see somebody separated
from their Consciousness sir I want
somebody stretched out I want somebody
go to the hospital and and talk to a
doctor you understand I want somebody
lumped up so bad at the end of the fight
that they looking like you know I don't
know how long it's gonna take for me
but I didn't get that what I got was a
dude that was trying to fight he reminds
me three four three
you're not gonna like me today okay
let's go
but it was it was it was kind of
disgusting but shout out to everybody
that came out and um the stream is doing
good numbers that is that was fantastic
I do appreciate everybody that showed up
all right this week what you doing
shout out to Maddie plays for putting
pink and Romper
downloaded right
um I'm gonna check that out shout out to
Phil Dominus maximum it's really
expensive what do you do now oh for
giving me Assassin's Creed Odyssey some
some I paid for and he's like you know
what king I know you just yeah yeah what
service is this that's this game pass
that's Game Pass so I'm one I'm running
all willy-nilly in it what
I never played the original uh Nino
Cooney
and it's in Game Pass right so I got
part two for my PlayStation remember
when we went to E3 and we had the big
blowout and splash out and I thought
that game was amazing yeah so
um part one came out and I couldn't
download it fast enough so I just ran
over to it and I I just quickly realized
that this Xbox is turning into an RPG
we're talking about it yeah I'm um I
played uh wulong the demo Yeah we
actually got to talk about that yeah
completely forgot about it for like an
hour it's like a little segment
dedicated yeah we'll do that we'll
figure it out so so that so okay I'll
save that for that okay um also um games
of gold is good this month my son wanted
to play portal 2. oh I forgot all about
it I never figured about it everybody
yeah but see that's that's the weak part
about it is you go in there just
download the three games even if you're
not gonna play them you never know when
you board they just go to your library
they might not show up there again so is
this um zombie music game is a 16-bit
game and you you're in the car and
you're driving and it's so dope and
different that you have to be on beat
with it and it takes me back to Guitar
Hero but it's like uh you know a zombie
uh shooter type of game is is it it's
different it's uh something that I would
have never tried and you mean mental
health singer no metal housing is more
like Doom right okay this is different
more like Doom this this thing is not
it's 16-bit okay 16-bit side scrolling
but you're on a track and it's a it's a
music game it's really good it's a
really good game and I was playing
Destiny shout out to all those people yo
ducky I'm back yeah
okay okay
free R Kelly five dollar Super Chat King
I ain't taking my foot off your neck oh
Halo's dead Microsoft Flagship title is
dead and Jim Ryan making boss moves so
you ain't taking your foot off my neck
but that CEO still got his foot on yours
[Music]
how are you gonna put your foot on
King's neck when the gods still got
their foot on yours that's the only
thing that's free on your body because
your hand is still behind your back
yo yo don't come for me unless I send
for you I told you keep it in the closet
girls
we doing that okay today
yo it's a new season of fortnite starter
today you know what's crazy fortnite is
so beastly and so extra with it they'll
be like yo we really want to start our
new season on a Sunday it's good send it
out like it yes yes they don't care
they're okay yeah it's funny you
mentioned wo long I did play that as
well and I played metal helsinger and I
completely forgot you're good you're
good I guess it wasn't on your steam
deck
on that Xbox and uh I know you forget
about that oh
not I'm not a fan of metal Hill singer
maybe I'll just show you oh I just look
at Rhythm games maybe but oh the way you
said it was like the performance or
something I was like oh no no promises
that's a rhythm game too it's a rhythm
so it's you you you shoot the enemies
and you attack the enemies in Rhythm to
uh like like hard rock like metal Rock
and the thing about it is that it it's
from what I see right maybe I just suck
you have your possibility there's
definitely a possibility it there's the
reticle pulses kind of and beat to into
the beat that you're supposed to follow
okay the thing about it is that the game
doesn't feel kinetic it doesn't feel
kinetic like like Doom in that respect
right where it's moving from one to the
next to the next the next in a smooth
way that kind of allows that Rhythm to
happen at least for me I didn't have
auto aim on or Auto sort of uh you know
when you focus on on an enemy so it was
all manual and it just didn't feel super
smooth
um and then there's the thing when you
start the game you calibrate it
calibrates the sounds and the pulsing to
like so you could exactly know when you
have to press the button and for
whatever reason it just didn't feel
smooth to me a lot of people been saying
they love it so again I it might just be
me yeah
the game definitely doesn't seem like a
game that would have fill me either so
yeah a lot of people saying they love it
I could not did you all right did you do
the soft thing when you you got any big
things extra difficult no no I went
right into normal whatever their normal
is the thing about it is is that you
know maybe I'm just not you know the
Heavy Metal the headband
okay okay but again the beat is the you
can tell where the beat is and where you
should be pressing and for whatever
reason is like trying to get into the
flow of it
called definitely needs to play that
game to understand what actually heavy
Green Day
anything but for strong anything what
for guitar I guess is heavy metal
don't do me like that
the gaming ninja himself the head with
every
battleships
I tell you what you want to hear what
you need to head shout out to find a
dude shout out to Mr batty plays had a
good one up there talking that TGs
talking that Yakuza like a dragon talk a
lot of games coming out did he play it
um yes yes okay yes we we have peace now
LSM Community get off this boy neck IO
peeking off his neck I was on him now
get honest they was like yo he got a new
one today it's coming for his Integrity
they was like hey he did [ __ ] dirty
yeah I did that thingy Romper you know
what I'm saying but now we good
everything good we got more stuff to
talk about on that had that ultimate
update also on the patreon with all my
man Chris ray gun go check that out that
was right when the news broke about
and then our last word but yo check out
the last word man he bought his tiger
Travis we had the legend asked the cross
yo as the cross is a legend out here
absolutely hilarious show we got some
balls from Mastercraft nobody he's never
told anybody on any show before highly
advised go check that out bus watch also
go support my Manny Bon test you already
know up there and then um who's in there
cooking in the kitchen with the wife and
the kitty oh shout out to Cynthia he's
like I made the kitchen cooking for the
wife and enjoy IOP No Doubt anyway
as far as what I've been playing on yo
cyberpunk y'all like
it's back like you like it right Edge
Runners set it off you know I went out
there when I was out there in Seattle I
saw the two episodes then I spotted to
watch the rest of the Droid on Netflix
that joint is absolutely for highly and
I'm not an anime
oh yeah I know dip down though right
tell about it y'all went viral off of
one of them joists
yeah we were hyped about it yeah the Cog
still needs to watch the attack on yeah
I gotta Watch Attack you're right but I
just got like I said I was out like one
of the best animes absolutely right wait
a second wait a second I got to call
fraud on you yeah
not you not you not you not you on your
man Tick Tock Master tick tock tick tock
I don't know who I don't know who he's
talking about yeah well this dude named
Tick Tock Master the master The Tick
Tock I just see you doing pop and
locking
you started me with Naruto
he's like your king this is and I told
you a couple times to watch Attack on
Titan because they told me that after
the fact that they did 500 episodes
of entertainment you said but you said
Attack on Titan was the best check this
out no I said one of the best this dude
this dude didn't tell me till after 300
episodes in
some of them has got filler
some of them
I'm all the way live now but yo yo all
right get Attack on Titan okay all right
step away from that you want you want
real joint go to Nora to First no do not
go to Naruto first it's way too long
you'll end up dropping it before
you have a little bit more of a
tolerance to anime than called yeah
Attack on Titan is like maybe 50 60
episodes I don't know exactly but like
yeah
which one should I do Attack on Titan on
your routine oh man yeah now you know
they're gonna come for you if you say it
wrong do you know that right I don't
know how to say it you know that right
turn around you're gonna see mad dudes
running down the block but they all
behind his back
but have you watched like the classic
stuff I don't watch Modern anime
whatever what have you watched have you
watched like vampire hunted games
you get mainstream with that classic
stuff don't be listening to this all
right yeah but I like the the grit like
I don't want this too happy and too many
smiling and too many color people
right that's what Maddie said so he said
that's what they're butt naked Giants
running outside and eating people
I need dip down did they go make the
call what should it be tackle the title
Naruto uh I mean I gotta respect uh
Naruto it's one of the pillars right
that set up towards the big three okay
KP what you say
I don't watch a lot of it too but I did
watch uh first season I think of Titan
the attack on the Titans oh okay so I
would suggest that because I'm not I'm
like Yukon all that yeah all that stuff
yeah but you can't be co-signing butt
[ __ ] giant cannibals
first and I also want them to decide
where it should be at but yeah it's it's
split there's something you are not
let's be real here you not watching
attack on I mean uh Naruto you're not
watching
Naruto is cringe-worthy of a lot of that
stuff but Shippuden isn't like Shippuden
for the most part it's very serious
though
what's this
no no hold on hold on okay there's
Naruto which is when they're kids like
14. then the Shippuden which is when
they're like 19. and then boruto which
is their kids show
like already it's too much
yeah we got the light Choice it's not
just the show
realist villains
and they do the most diabolical things
respectful stuff yes yes
they got a bunch of thanos's like people
who make things that they think's right
for everyone but it's really they're
they're crazy but 500 episodes no you
don't have to watch all you don't have
to walk oh so which is
yeah which one of the three is to start
there oh you gotta you have to it's
Naruto's the original one you could just
if you don't like the cringe-worthy
stuff just watch a YouTube video they
say where the ball at they say what they
say
calm yourself calm yourself some people
saying Cowboy Bebop too that's another
one yeah they said you gotta watch
Jujitsu kegs in if you want
okay fire all right yo this is real okay
cool oh I know what it is um it is the
echo from the zoo so you do it right
Double K with the zoo with the zoom you
I'll Focus you
no doubt all right so we good to go
everybody caught up on that but yeah I'm
gonna put my own ones in there after a
time
just ask what Chicago play between those
two sir please and they're um yeah so
Saturday already too late Edge one is
because that's what it was lit so I got
right back at the time [ __ ] shout out to
them yo you know what's Liz off
the series act series X or whatever you
you register on cyberpunk GLG
cross progression on the steam yeah
that's right that's right that's right
sax Cloud Safe Way exactly I saved that
no hold down go back and forth see
that's what I want I'm tired of losing
progression if I go from different
platform to me that's what this gaming
thing is going like that's what I want
to see you know what I'm saying that's
what Phil want to do yeah like these
mother dudes they'll be snitching around
here
they just cared about about their gamers
but I think I think because after like
those big three had those giants like
fillers where it's like seven eight
hundred episodes anime has kind of
shifted towards shorter shows that are
actually straight to the point an attack
on Titan is probably the biggest show
that's out right now no doubt no doubt
so we're doing that
um checking up in my tech it back here
yeah I know that over time
to call you after you saw the Tekken
eight oh God we're gonna talk we gotta
say that for the for the state
department
I'm training these young boys
she put my mind at ease yesterday yeah
when I see that look we're gonna get
into all that we get to the state of
play we get an Xbox Tokyo game show but
I've been in my bag um and then last of
course yesterday so that's what it but
um yeah yeah so Sam you want to get the
uh what we got to do for the for the
business before we get there yeah and
let me just copy this last Super Chat
real quick you want me to do the super
chats and then get into that okay
give me one second
let me ask you a question
are we gonna show them the Secret
Surprise thing oh we're gonna keep that
in under wraps because I mean that's the
big thing I think we can just wait here
all of us have to see yeah we should
wait we should wait oh some of us don't
have it yet well somebody didn't go to
the Post Office 20 miles and somebody
didn't get there until Saturday and they
already said they couldn't find my
apartment and took that sucker right
back to the police
I was ready to put Oxford ready to put
it around myself
when you leave my apartment when you
leave my apartment there's an apartment
to the right it's like it's like FedEx
drives in the alleyway that my they both
these apartments resign and they're like
it's too hard
yeah
all right I got these super chess let's
go heard out what goes on in those
alleys
we got Brad Ward from a brad word
formerly Brad words right absolutely
five dollars shout out to Phil Spencer
for giving IOP that Elite S2 or hook up
clever use of GoPro by addicting yeah
that was that was hilarious then we got
Sith Lord uh remember for two months
shout out to you sir Lord Braun Sony
needs to make statements like adults not
children this will eventually hurt them
in future deals and Acquisitions
then we got Sith Lord again no it's the
same one never mind then we got dovey
put the crust in the chat but do
remember for 22 months up into Lord
bronze salute to you sir thank you
brother no doubt and we have Hardy
Chennai five dollar Super Chat
salute to the Lord salute to Bonnie Ross
for keeping Halo relevant after Bungie
God bless with her family situation and
future endeavors yes yes that's what
we're going to talk about every day now
let's put the crests in the chat for the
newest member of the realm Texas spelled
t-e-k-s-i-s Texas Texas
is that all no don't know we got two
more two more cup and we got a Cypher
pole 92 remember for one year two pounds
big up to the Lords have a blessed day
everyone you as well pressed up y'all
come on then we have Elliot shlomovic
member for 29 months thank you sir thank
you if you have less tolerance to anime
tropes slash humor Attack on Titan is
the way Naruto is the goat though if
very long and has she put in Post Time
skip okay so overall as it is a goal but
for me I said okay I like Ellie look I I
think Attack on Titan will be a better
anime for you to get back into an
amazing then you can broaden your garage
finished right they're both done Attack
on Titan has one more part what's funny
is they're they're doing this new thing
it's like Attack on Titan's final season
part two part three
right now but everything that's out
right now is Dub so if you want to look
English you know the original Japanese
voices like all that has that UF started
yeah yeah there you go
I just I just throw a little grenade
I I have seen the you know the posts and
people have been dming me we will be
doing another Community Day
um you know hopefully we can do it next
Saturday I don't know if Saul is able to
do it next Saturday well we're gonna
play we're gonna play some more Halo
that's supposed to be dead ain't the
right kill I don't know
um
so we will be getting on that hopefully
next week and then going on past that
it's like I said we'll we'll be doing
like the gold stuff to to determine when
we do another one instead of cockroaches
anime attic has to watch sports
I did watch sports last night and I'm a
shout out my man for showing up to my
stream yeah I'm gonna watch I'm gonna
watch the Anderson Silva fight though
because I messed with Anderson Silva no
no yeah absolutely Legend spider no
doubt
no we got a couple of more real quick we
got uh
Philip one no Beast two dollars Super
Chat thank you sir appreciate that then
we have the most
Super Chat
fortnite season 4 launched today who's
coming with me I'll play after the after
the podcast what's funny is they have
this like new little thing where you can
turn into like you know what like
Terminator turns into like that metal
slime stuff like they really turned into
it now and I'm like I'm like look you've
made yourself a smaller
top more Cog I need you to read this
window oh wow what's up about red and
blade yeah you gotta rebound
two pound Super Chat Cog should watch
swallowed star it's deep pause time on
you time on you sir
I'm like why he want me to read this
we got Mr Irishman member for 15 months
shout out to you sir watch the chainsaw
man trailer you haven't watched it yet
but I heard it's some music
that's it we're good okay so before we
move on to the topics before we move on
to uh dip down
real quick patreon yeah shout out to all
of you guys who support us on patreon
every single month we appreciate it we
love you all so here are these giveaways
you know we fly through this stuff so
here we go
so the winner of our 10 patreon uh
giveaway
Karma Funk
[ __ ] okay okay absolutely shout out to
you sir no doubt all right and the
winner of our 20 gift card giveaway is
[Music]
David hopright David hot right
oh by the way um Attack on Titan is
smoking the real Tony chat 62 37 just
won't let y'all yeah yeah well no I told
you it would like fire attack look
Naruto is an amazing anime it's just
like it's it has bad pacing and a lot of
parts of the anime and Attack on Titan
literally from episode one to where they
are now is like oh my God when's this
ever gonna end oh yeah I would just put
pain right then there would be no more
Titans dad well yeah I mean obviously
like all Mighty push oh he said Naruto's
garbage addict oh my goodness
flame don't like Halo go to work
play was just angry and different [ __ ]
he just want to go against the Green you
know yeah
no reason
all right
I was gonna say uh Harvey I'm gonna do
your poll man I'm gonna do your pulse
all right okay
that that's the point
of your vocals
get to yourself
give away for the month of September
goes to
oh wow this is family Lord valicon
appreciate you sliding us that extra
bread to win you know what I'm saying
I think that's the first time like any
of like personal people we know is the
first time yeah I mean I know it's
because I have like eight eight people
in there and they they and everyone
there is we've had people before but
it's like people that are that that like
work directly with us so it would not be
fair yeah valicon is that's family
that's love but he doesn't work there's
been a couple of times you've won that
you've had to re-roll it and it so oh
yeah
a lot of times they won yeah they want
it to re-roll yeah so we all caught up
yep we're cut up thank you oh as always
we appreciate your support and your love
it is much appreciated also two super
chats came in
um let me get heartbeat shadeen five
dollar Super Chat saudi's poll you're a
gamer if a you play on playstation B you
don't play on other platforms or C
appreciate playing a quality tax and
that poll right now is in the chat
in Quality Tax then we have flame
remember for 24 months howdy buckaroos
Nintendo was waiting to name the news of
the game to see how Jimmy was going to
be acting perfect fit for that name have
a great show you know flame be sitting
there talking smack about Naruto but he
probably capping for uh Splatoon make it
make sense
that we have before we move on these are
going to be the last ones before we move
on we got sin Vendetta 20 Super Chat
thank you so much more music let's see
Cog if you want to experience with real
heavy metal music is you need to listen
to some death core slash metal core
bands like Lorna Shore knocked loose The
Devil Wears Prada oh band of sacrifice G
brand of sacrifice okay and Arc Spire
archspire Spotify
this is too white for me I was in the
shot and shout out to my men on Midway
monster we happy he picked me up in the
big truck but he had all the metal
joints rocket like he put me on in the
big truck did he have you know what it
is
shout out to my bed you already know
what it is but yeah was listening Pumped
Up Kicks
do me a favor hit me in the DM with like
the Spotify on some links and I'll
listen to it
last one then we got
five dollar Super Chat y'all see Lucia's
thickness
as a Latino myself that's the last thing
I representation I like to see yeah
Lucia has some cake there's some cake
there
we're referring that solve as game leak
we're not referring that yeah
[Laughter]
get down being patient man
yes we're good let's go he knows what he
got himself
two-hour intros and then the show start
I doubt if we got into what the laws
have been playing we got to switch off
focus to the Lords of dip down podcast
the video game system history and of
course what led them to creating the dip
down anime and games channel so Lord
Stevie Ray Lords KP let's get into some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you in the game it should
start with Stevie Ray first
oh first uh consoles man so I started
off in the 90s right
and uh I was doing that uh NES
I remember my first game actually I
still remember it was uh but it's an SNK
it was guerrilla warfare okay okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I started from
there then I went to uh of course the
Super NES that was the Nintendo dude in
the beginning okay and uh like all of us
because you just talked about uh
guerrilla warfare
um was there any other standouts that
you had with the NES uh like any
Hallmarks did you get a chance to play
Zelda the gold cartridge or super punch
out I mean punch out or anything like
that oh yes yes thank you for refreshing
my memory you know a little six-year-old
Ray can't remember everything
yeah yeah it's a punch out yeah that was
uh Mike that was the one that I played
all the time as well but I was too I was
still a little too young to really
appreciate like the ninja gaidens and
all that Legend of zeldas and all that
that was later on and when I got the N64
yeah so that the funny story within 64.
I got that only because my uncle
is a little bit of a monster right here
he's outside
oh okay oh you went to college
he had to go study abroad
came back came back with his majors and
secured it's a little up north it's no
problem no hard knocks this is what it
is
before he left he said Mijo I'm Gonna
Keep I gotta keep you off the streets
okay so here's this you play this here's
the n64.
going on there yeah yeah yeah so man I I
played that every single day yeah
okay one of my favorite titles I think
me personally the best wrestling game
uh oh
WWF no mercy let's go
so let's subscribe to that podcast
subscribe
some patreon let's go let's go that's it
the goat wrestling let's go let's go it
was just different man they're just
doing things that are Innovative then
man another quick little story you know
again don't don't judge me on my
character naming right because I was
like you know your boy's like nine so
good I made my character I had him what
was his name his name was mad dog and I
made my team don't feel bad man dip down
they they're very respectful towards
younger audience
foreign
[Laughter]
we're going through the tag team run and
all that stuff and you know the standard
thing to do in video games you know
you're getting pinned oh no but your
teammate comes out like kicks him real
quick breaks it right yeah so you know
we're doing a title match with the
Champions and all this and then I'll get
pinned I'm like don't worry I got a
bigger bigger come out come on my boy
just stays at the Rope
we're beefing and now we split up and I
and I'm a kid and I'm just thinking like
how is this possible
I said I made you who you are big girl
I forgot they had the little story
converted yeah man it was crazy and so
you know what I made my own teammate
again and then he got his teammate I
can't remember who it was so we then
went to WrestleMania you know just kind
of Rope A Dope him and just ended them
and they became champions again so yeah
that is beasty as hell if you think
about it as a child you sitting there
he's like yeah my partner got my back
because I made him right this is his job
hold on I got a break protocol Comfort
Jeremy Brown talk about stop it
SmackDown versus
407.
you about to get kicked out the chat
for this nonsense
nostalgic glasses
yeah in terms of a game that's actually
fun to play competitively without crazy
yeah versus somebody you playing the
computer bro
[Laughter]
probably like my second favorite console
of all time the Dreamcast okay yeah so
you know I'm playing the classics on
there I'm playing Crazy Taxi and play
Power Stone you know I'm playing the
Sonic adventures and all that Soul
Weaver any ready Rumble already a rumble
yes yes yes yes yes absolutely
absolutely and then uh it got to a point
where my pops came to me he's like
listen kid this is this game a little
too expensive
need to make a move
we're not doing this uh PS3 the 360 and
the Wii all over again because I was
getting all the consoles you know just
you know we made it happen and then I
shot the pops and I was watching right
now yeah and then uh so I saw this game
and it locked it in for me Gears of War
okay Gears of War locked in the 360 for
me and to be truthfully
um I don't think without the 360 I'm not
here because the 360 is how I met Amber
okay oh yeah so I met Amber weed you
know this is like 15 year old Ray at
this point you know we and we just best
friends for like you know 10 years at
the 10 year mark we both single right
here like we've been homies for like a
decade to see what's up so like without
the 360 dip down probably doesn't exist
I'm not here talking to you guys so
that's what's up the 360. my whole life
in a certain direction that's what's up
I love it I love it we got to get KP
because he been patient we gotta give me
yeah go get some Focus so he's right in
the Next Room just pull him over
[Laughter]
what was the first consoles things that
got you in the game bro
so I got like a decade already so I'm
I'm back in you guys
so it started out I'm gonna wear
something to eat
educated get educated get something to
drink get a snack yeah yeah
we're going down memory lane exactly
respect your OG let's go so I grew up in
a uh uh two big houses or a lot of
relatives okay family cousins you know
older younger same age
so I did a lot of networking okay okay
back then I I'll still do it today
that's how me and this guys together
that's what's up so uh uh I went to a
cousin's house
I remember vividly because I was like
four going on five all right it's crazy
so he he had that he had that Atari
he let me play that thing uh he he had
the uh the first one said okay 2600 2600
yeah you got the switches on it like a
piece of furniture
he had that thing I played it the whole
time we was over there at the visit I
told my dad I said I want a game
so my birthday comes uh September let's
go so they surprised me with that
Nintendo NES oh I had to I had to Value
the uh the Power Pad with the zapper
wait you got the power pack yeah ain't
no kid on my block at the power but
y'all had money yeah
on my block had that power that went for
a certain demographic yeah
continue I think that was that was like
88. yeah well we got it so you know
Nintendo been out a few years so they
had that pack and they had the three
games on the one cartridge yeah yeah the
duck hunt
um
ice climb I think right no mines had uh
it had the tracking field stuff
okay yeah yeah yeah so we we had that
joint and also they bust out one more
game oh
let me get the beat right yeah
or when you lose in the God yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's that okay cause that's
the joke that goes side to side
yo he had the best karate slippers ever
yo his Charlotte slipper game
the black hair yeah
yeah so once I got that I was in a whole
nother Dimension so
it was all over it and it was hard too
because you know there was not that many
TVs in the house so you can't sit there
and play all day so when I played I
played
to my brother got old enough because I'm
like four years older than him so uh we
got the my cousin got the network I'm
like my friend he got some games he
don't want oh yeah my dad was like tell
him to bring him over he brought over a
whole stack of games I think my dad
bought them all from him
some of those games was the original
Zelda oh it was a gold cartridge yes sir
Mantra oh let's go I know you get that
lives cold that up up down down oh
that's right b-a-p-a start just tell
tell me you have Russian attack and you
was out yeah
I'm coming to KP house KP got it oh
let's go
yo when you coming home because you got
the gays bro
Jackal
oh wow yeah uh um
Simon's Quest yes first one second that
was the RPG one yeah yeah
uh I can I can keep going off that was
the first one with a battery backup I
believe
I think Zelda was Zelda Zelda with it
okay I remember Russia's tattoo do it
like jump from GI Joe I remember him
yeah
my birthday come around the next year
okay okay with a sports game two sports
games actually double Bibles
you're so amazed by them Cinemas
I did not care I just did anything to
get in that pocket so I could just dunk
on them
britishly lost again
wow
put them on about that double dribble
double dribble good teeth
yes oh and then to me best beat em Up
game Double Dragon Double Dragon oh but
yeah
yeah unfortunately you did not
experience the superior version but um
you didn't have a Master System solved
could you educate the band or why was
the superior version I did Superior yes
it had two players sir
I knew that and it was actually arcade
accurate yes the one for the the
Nintendo but I don't know what that was
the level and you had to fight by
yourself yeah by yourself yeah yeah that
was the day we knew that some of these
joints these arcade points
Oh no you're good um
another one of my favorites where we had
some battles on techno bowl of course oh
yes of course
of course so you had all these stack of
NES jump off so now you just staying in
the nas what's the progression yeah
you know what came next
you betrayed I did oh yeah
I feel how easy and quick he said I did
yeah he did like he had no problem but
here's the thing I went I went to the
games
uh it might have been that Spider-Man
game was it Amazing Spider-Man yes
go yeah so I I think that was uh either
89 or 90. okay okay it's about time I
got that um I mean I'm not even alive
yet
don't put his age like Stevie Ray
don't you do that I'm still I'm still
I'm still not alive either look get get
in the young quarter yeah
[Laughter]
people wonder why I got trust issues
listen man this is crazy
you know who was the most popular
musician in the world during that time
over whoa
oh man
[Laughter]
Joe Montana football yeah yeah yeah
Michael
you know the games were have voices you
know the graphics were better which I
still loved it in the Nintendo because I
still kept collecting games you know
that I can get my hands on oh and that
collection got up to like 200 cartridges
crazy and I was all into the Genesis so
I was I was knee-deep in it all right
let me ask you anything that came out
with Genesis almost almost everything
the fantasy Stars the Streets of Rage oh
yes okay oh that's my second favorite
beat em up the Streets of Rage
what was um Strider was 16 Megs the
eight Meg cards
yeah that you beat my my house I'll kick
you out
give me like it's been a brand new first
day
playing the game I'm like oh this is
dope
see the Drake roll credits on my journey
I'm like yo we got this rule like you're
not supposed to finish no man gang like
we just been born
you know it's funny speaking of that
gaming speaking of gaming moments where
you made a co-op game in a like a
non-call game into a call game because
we used to do it with GTA like the older
ones it used to be like you die you pass
the controller well at the time I knew
the cheat codes and like like I let the
controller switch hands like five or six
times
the dude I was playing with once you use
the bathroom and get something to drink
and then you never died no I died but he
came back he's like amazing how you been
out running these cops this long I don't
know
so pretty much almost everything
damn I I tried to make sure I missed
nothing because what about Gunstar
Heroes gun star treasure god okay okay
yeah I'm Blockbuster I was a video store
Bandit oh I think it was that guy I was
so notorious my parents they they had
them make me a card for myself
but did you do the trick like we used to
kind of hide it was that you know oh yes
you go in and you hide it in another
section yes yes
I'll be like oh this came out and I'll
take that I'll go take it to uh uh like
special interest area
he put it in the history the history
section
like it was it was like rental culture
was a thing like yeah yeah man the
barber pop video store or you had the
Blockbuster next to you there was a
limited amount of games or tickets to
you know to actually pick up to actually
go Reddit for the weekend dudes that hit
that store on Friday if you ain't if it
was a wrap because they gonna hold on to
it for the week and losing eat the late
late
fee
it was it was a culture like people
understand like the rental scene was
insane for gamers and that's what it is
because a lot I kept the towel the tail
end of it like yeah but it's like
because what it was is like yo we didn't
have the bread I mean everybody wasn't
like okay we had a bread for everything
I don't know so I just well that worked
apparently when he was out here
finessing I was using the word network
I like it that's Ohio
I wasn't buying stuff at that time like
during those times but uh someone told
me that I can't remember I heard it from
that like when the like the Blockbusters
and stuff started uh surfacing
everywhere they started taking such a
huge dip out of the um
out of the movie Market they started
charging like a hundred dollars for for
a VHS or something like that did that
happen
I don't remember that no I mean nothing
because nothing here nothing was day and
date back then so it was it was and back
then it was you talking about months
upon months he's talking about the
bootlegs oh bootlegs for sure I don't
know what it was
when the bootleg Market came up
um that was out of control because I'll
go to the movies and they go in the
movies at 12 o'clock noon yeah right so
if you cut in school you'll catch a
bootlegger yeah they already paid the
Usher he already hit the Usher off with
the guap here you go and he's sitting
there with a whole Camp because remember
the back of the days
so he's sitting there with a whole
series X
yeah and people just walking past come
on man sit down
yo it's real it's real though KV say
he's doing that
did the switch over now were you tempted
for any like turbo or any of that stuff
or what was the next progression after
that so I I had the other older cousin
okay he got the turbo Graphics there we
go I like that though yeah that dude
right that's my guy so so he he got he
got some incredible games uh two of my
favorites was on there was Keith Curry
oh
Vegas keep ing your Alpha officers right
kid you know that was the packing that
was the packing guys the packing little
drain they look like a little Voltron he
big building yeah
it did I'm glad you said China Warrior
yeah because China Warrior like we talk
about Bruce Lee coming forward
that's what I realized how what Sprites
were yeah because they were the
character took up the entire screen and
the enemies took up the entire screen
all he did was move his arm though yeah
but China Warrior bro and them both
fights and they used to have a little
shots
you felt like he was doing something you
was watching something with that yeah
that oh that rock there was evil out
there
[Laughter]
yeah shout out to China
oh yeah yeah yeah my cousin yeah yeah he
that yo that okay so that takes a lot of
of quijones man like to you're not
you're in a place where there's Nintendo
and it's Sega that's the populace right
so you're in the schoolyard and that's
the populace then you got those weird
old dudes in the corner like me right
probably wearing all black with upside
down cross listen to heavy yeah heavy
metal music right right and I'm
listening to guns and roses and all this
other stuff but
um heavy metal is that what you're
listening to yeah
but uh
and then I had turbo graphics
so that you really you was a loner yeah
right because you couldn't trade games
with nobody
right so when you brought a game you was
for dolo so you was really just showing
off like people come to your house and
they were like what's that this is box
Adventure box right yeah and you throw
that in your boy get crazy when you eat
some meat pulse
was no joke so yeah your cousin had the
turbo so you gotta just check that out
yeah yeah so
um so I'm knee deep in Sega okay okay
let's go we we get the Sega CD oh
yeah everything
my dad's job they they had the Christmas
bonus that's what did it okay because I
was getting maybe one or two games a
year and and lucky if I got a system
that Christmas okay
this is No Game Pass error to talk about
it the Blockbuster was my game my uh
Game Pass
and was it the kids living in that in
that Blockbuster talk talk about it all
these kids with a gaming talking that's
how it really was continue yeah so so
next I think we get like mid 90s before
to 64. so that the turbo no the
32x32x came out got that
which 32x did you have did you have the
the separate one that was uh that had
the Sega um all in one joint or did you
happen
you made that you made the Tower of
Power
Game Genie cartridge on top
did you take it too high with the Sonic
and Knuckles
yes I did that dude that was a fighter
Sonic and Knuckles put the game on top
crazy crazy crazy crazy
so what was the 32x you rocked it was
just real quick
um uh I had Knuckles chaotic yeah
yeah it was okay I didn't realize how
limited it was I had this uh shooting
game what is it Corpus killer
um the Corpus killer corpse killer yeah
corpse killer yeah yeah yeah I had that
of course the Doom it was this game
called Cosmic uh it was a fight game
Cosmic song I know what you're talking
about yeah
Cosmic Carnage I think it was called I
know what you're talking about yeah they
only had like two fighting games and
um they had the virtual Fighters that
came out for it they had that game
actually it had another one it was the
other one came out for Sega Mortal
Kombat 2 on there yeah
yeah yeah they have more they have more
monks in the background yeah
the extra roll of monks
[Laughter]
that's when you rocking Sega all the way
through that was it Saturn next was it
dream like wait what was the progression
or did now we get in the PlayStation
like what happened like what from that
point absolutely I'm second five Saturn
came
yeah it was over yeah
and that game sections went yeah yeah
yeah and I was like this this
Sony thing is crazy out here no doubt
before we get into it so I wanted to
know give me some for soft give me some
Saturn stand that was though for you
like what was the joke of course you had
the Daytona USA yeah yeah
man because Champion Edition kind of
fixed up stuff
oh I had um
I mean unless you was an import heavy
dude and that's the only way the Sega
Saturn shine
cartridge in the back and you was
getting these import games in other than
that they kind of left that dude out
there to drive important the Dreamcast
right behind them yeah get them out of
here
at the time too uh back in the gyms I
was a street fighter fan so okay of
course I bought Street Fighter movie for
that Saturday oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I wanted to see oh who had extra
this and extra that and I would buy Game
Informer these dudes fools
I mean I did it I did it for Tomb Raider
I did it for Tomb Raider games and I
mean nine times out of ten the the
PlayStation
bison was also Gomez Adams yes yeah
don't say nothing about Van Damme
playing in America
what about like what about like the like
like the standouts like a guardian
heroes or a panda Dragoon or something
like that okay I had Knights yeah
definitely nice it came with their own
controller yeah yeah
of course you know Sonic was on there of
course yeah but it that died off quick
yeah because me networking a buddy of
mine yeah
he went and rented a PlayStation mm-hmm
so we went to the video store I went
with them they got the system okay uh he
got like five games I've never seen
anybody win five games I got one ball so
he got that and we was like oh my God
this Tekken
um
yeah then Crash Bandicoot oh we had to
let Jason Ruben all talk about that
continue
uh I can keep going
um
we had to go lose his mind if you had
that battle arena
yeah we rented that too let's go so he
wound up getting one uh for his birthday
because he we tried before you buy that
was yeah that's it yeah so he he tried
it he got it first and I still was like
uh I like it but I'm not ready to jump
straight
I betrayed the hell out of this [ __ ]
I was like they not doing this this is
this PlayStation I was like oh I'm out
that was the first time I saw a sound
system 11 Tekken in the arcade
and you know how it used to go King when
you get to all candy come on and be like
that it doesn't look the same boy when I
because the system 11 board was in the
PlayStation one and after taking on it
in the cramp and I know I saw it at your
crib because I was like oh my gosh
they had graphics and endings and sub
bosses eyes like I said I'm gonna sit
sorry I made it the only thing that they
didn't do is when you're picking them in
the animation screen yes in the arcade
they mouth they bout to move but yeah
slightly less Ram or something in the
PlayStation yeah you're absolutely right
kick I forgot about that I remember all
of that because I was the guinea pig yes
right so you know how you was trying
before you was buying all that no I was
at the store like give me that an hour
number one mooch I would come over
and see what's popping and get the
leftovers there where he bought the
trade out he's kind of lion because
he had a PC uh and he had the internet
yes yes so we would download one video
Yeah that would take four hours and
he'll tell his moms don't touch them
don't pick up the phone don't pick up
your phone
but
anyways so KP so rook and we go we're
gonna move into the game we go along but
um yeah so so from that place down place
that you say no you do not betraying
places you stayed you you didn't do it
you did I went back home what started me
oh he went back home
okay Ultra 64. okay so that's when you
wake up with Stevie Ray on this on the
164.
[Laughter]
because I know some history I know you
like it like yeah no no but he likes
systems any system that got four ports
on this on the front yes that's what I'm
realize okay any system we got the four
point continue yeah so of course you
know my cousins and brother and them are
they're gamified now too dude so I can't
play by myself like I did back in the
NES before they were babies right
so I had to get something where we all
can cruel could play yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know the boys come over yes so
64. yes my parents get it they fought
like hell to get one uh I think
something with Toys R Us I think because
we wanted that gold in there oh best
pause music in the history the game will
continue yeah golden eye that out of the
game pass got to get past coming through
yeah I got the Duke Nukem oh
I think the best wrestling game ever oh
is Revenge part of the family it's part
of the family part of the family part of
the family that's definitely the best
WCW game ever that's part of the fan
that's acceptable that was THQ right HQ
yeah
THQ best fighting system going
competitively continue yeah Randall you
know of course the Mario cards yeah
Smash Bros come out yeah Game Changer
look at look at the attic face
I know
Smash Brothers
I played a lot of Smash Brothers like I
I wouldn't say like I think Smash Bros
is like a big part of I was mainly on
the PlayStation for a lot of that time
so okay no doubt yeah
two of the ones I saved birthday money
for what Ocarina of Time
[Music]
um
of course that um it was some other
games on there but I think
I think my first N64 game was Glover and
Star Wars Rogues those are the two games
everybody hated Glover the governor was
it was the joint that was inside the bin
and then you were just you know going
there like get Glover that
yeah yeah yeah if you think about it
like in hindsight now is actually a
unique platforming game that you've done
a little bit differently probably could
have went a lot different for them yeah
you do play so real quick but is there
any system you did not have okay
I'm gonna flash through this yeah I had
an older neighbor a couple houses down
he had Panasonic 3DS
we got to play on that a lot too okay
that running gun yes uh gax
um
uh uh The Naughty Dog game oh wait the
Warriors
yeah
no doubt yeah yeah so we played on that
my cousin wound up getting one
and then from there
um we had we had a we had a house fire
so I lost all my game and stuff oh no
oh yeah we lost all my Genesis
collection Nintendo Tower of Power
64. you know I had gold cartridge of you
know all that oh so that was returning
balance into the force yeah so oh that
was Uncle Bibby fell asleep smoking a
cigarette
[Music]
that's crazy that's crazy so I had to
start over from Ground Zero of course
this time uh 99 is coming so you know
what came out oh yeah
so I got one that was a game changer
three Cash let's go yep got that that
chick now that opened the door for me
into online gaming yeah okay yeah so I
was I was Fantasy Star I had the
keyboard yeah a horse them I found the
AOL thing in the middle
put that in there I would play at night
so nobody pick up the phone
Mom smart you know playing 2K NBA 2.
visual concepts baby let's go Power
Stone and yeah you know all that Soul
Calibur so yeah
oh absolutely Soul Caliber yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh a berserk what was
that the Berserker sort of the berserk
yeah yeah yeah
he said he's saying it too with yes he's
like yeah yeah there's no place I've
seen it I ain't respect greatness so
you've seen your man he don't win and
got one after he tried he brought he
went yeah he knew denying it Krispy
clean he got that you doing everything
but that yeah let's let's get back is
there a time that you picked up a
Playstation yes so during that Dreamcast
time you got the most expensive one to
three the part Playstation three
no no no all right we got a PS1 okay all
right
we had a PlayStation we didn't get the
PS one we had the PlayStation it was
before they changed it okay so we did
get that and I had a couple of games I
forgot that was right before the fire
right before got it
the PlayStation for burning down
[Laughter]
you notice he said I had a PlayStation
not a PS1 PS1 was a little hamburger
when that was a little bit more stable
the other one he had was wild and
unpredictable
oh this is it so I got that tried it
fell in love with it yes PS2 was out
then so a lot of people don't know
PlayStation had to lock on GTA yes yep
yes and I was like a buddy brought me
over that I was working with because I'm
working now I bought the Xbox that was
the one I bought myself your first joke
all right so no more finessing no more
finessing no no more convincing
yeah I didn't have to network as hard
yeah that's right that's the word that's
the word right so
so
um
I like that I like that
continue yeah he let me play GTA and I
was just stunned because at the time my
wife to be uh she came with me and I was
like oh God
[Laughter]
I did I did I told her I was like
[Laughter]
she made some moves and happy birthday
awesome that's how she got married
I just got married she was like he said
he gotta have that I gotta have him
I know
shout out to Wifey she she been in it
with me and then fast fast forward both
of y'all yeah
so of course I'm knee-deep in the Xbox
game uh
a fault like hell to try to get uh a 360
because they were hard to get yep she
tried to even get in I didn't even know
it so that's what's up correct for
Christmas she was like I couldn't get
one but here she gave me the money to
buy one that's what's up and I wound up
finding one a few few weeks later of
course and of course they got me to my
Apex of gaming with the Apex uh to this
day oh with the 360. no doubt okay oh
here we go we already kind of got what
you call so yeah
pretty much stayed in that lane yeah
yeah yeah so oh no no no no no no so I I
do mess with PlayStation ever since I
got PS2 okay okay I was getting I get
all the exclusives on Playstation of
course I said gow over there let's be
honest with us man you bought that
PlayStation too because you wanted to
you didn't want to make PlayStation mad
again PlayStation
[Laughter]
Insurance back in the day they would say
do you want to protect yourself from
PlayStations
for 9.99 we can keep the PlayStation
away let me ask you a question so when
you walk out the house you unplug the
PlayStation
I got a I got a panamaxes plugged into
now okay okay
so look let's bring It Forward because I
know we went extra long ones the stories
are great so like I got to get more
Stevie Ray lady Amber Lord KP dip down
game step down podcast like how does the
the merging of the worlds come together
how do y'all link together
I'll try to make it quick so pretty much
it is it was my idea in the very
beginning 2019 I was just like hey you
know what and I met my girlfriend at the
time she must have gone saying now I'm
making moves we're making moves now
blessings blesses you know I was like
hey you want to start this podcast with
me you know just to see what's up it was
more of a hobby back in 2019 you know we
didn't know what we were doing we're on
here like just eating burgers and things
like that doing taste tests and stuff
like that smacking our lips
we're just doing a bunch of silly stuff
on there but it wasn't and of course
2020 it's kind of sucked for everybody
so uh we didn't really do much with it
but it wasn't until like 2021 where I
started taking it serious and I was like
no I really want to do something with
this so I started researching checking
out a lot of these uh you know podcasts
all these big companies and all that and
then AP directs me he's like listen I
know you're messing with these guys and
those guys but let me turn on to these
iron Lords let me tell you how the boom
sticks
yeah yeah yeah so start taking it
serious and then in 2022 comes on and
you know KP was just the at the time he
wasn't really a part of just yet but he
was telling me like oh no dude just do
this yes and then we had him we hadn't
come on a couple times and it wasn't
until 2022 and this year I was like you
know what in that KP he fired Yeah Boy
knowledgeable man you heard it right now
yeah he said they gave us a history
lesson all right and so and then you
know we need a little more controversy
on the on the podcast
so Casey he'd be getting into with the
chat sometimes ah you did that we got a
k for your Andre too
we got two kids
we got a white and black yes
doing the YouTube stuff and then you
know deal with dip down games anime and
I I I've split it off since then just to
focus in more on our Target audiences so
that's why you'll see dip down games and
separate a YouTube dip Diana maybe no
doubt here we are now just kicking it
with everybody no love love shot doing
um love the anime aspect too and again
lady Amber you know next time he's
supposed to be you're watching he's
supposed to be on here no no scared but
um now what I like about one was the
hardest because trying to scare people
on the yeah
what's wrong on me well you know she's
in the vicinity somewhere
she's at the door just opening it
because I wanted to give up her flowers
on two things one I think the horror
streams are absolutely hilarious I was
watching the dead by daylight joint
laughing and the bike is just catching
all the thought y'all putting y'all up
more Hooks and y'all scared but no you
were scared with the music over here
but also the anime portion because you
kind of like be in a way where you was a
novice right to the joint and then she's
like the expert she's like no no this
isn't it and then obviously the game's
live all three of y'all come together
you know the nkb dropped the knowledge
and stuff like that so yo that's that's
no man continue doing what y'all doing
and um love the production value I'm
gonna have to get some tips from y'all
how to step us up because y'all
production value is very very sweet
feeling what y'all doing out there so
I'm gonna get some attention I
appreciate it yeah man so just tell the
people real quick um we're getting into
the final questions but like how can
they find y'all where y'all at you know
what I'm saying what's up with with the
content at yeah man just hit up uh on
YouTube uh dip down anime and then uh
dip down games maybe a little bit harder
to find because I just create that
challenge only like a month old so okay
you might have to I might have to like
Drop links like that and chat for it but
yeah we got to put that link in bro you
got to put that link in yeah that's
we're mainly on YouTube you know we kind
of messing around Twitter okay down the
games dip down anime and the same thing
with Instagram and we try to mess with
that Tick Tock but we don't have a lower
tick tock on our side so yeah Tick Tock
Master Tick Tock Master here yo listen
man
when you have your glasses on your attic
yeah
man salute to what you call it for
father so we gotta ask the question that
we asked all the guests in the realm you
know what I'm saying start with true
Lord Stevie Ray also turn your bike up
just a little bit complain it like a
little bit because we want to hear more
Stevie Ray in the dip down and you
holding them back
he's giving you the Finesse voice
there we go so like I did let's start
with Stevie Ray
top five video games or franchises of
all time
your price uh video games you kind of
kind of heard uh maybe one or two you
know top five games would be uh you know
like WWE no mercy hours and uh 100 of
hours playing that game there's a war
because it changed my life forever
um and then one of my favorite Shooters
of all time is the times time slithers
too
remember that yeah man I
is the spiritual successor
um what's that game of death Loop Maybe
oh yeah yeah I don't know I don't know I
I didn't get a chance to play Death Loop
yet we will talk about that soon yeah
yeah got those three I know times four
coming out soon though so I'm excited
about that oh that's what's up no doubt
and then the top top two uh I would say
number two for me uh game I love is a
Bioshock the whole frame classic yep and
then I'm a sucker for narrative you know
okay and so my my number one franchise
is going to be life is strange wow
first season of life is strange it's
something it's it's to this day the best
episode of Game that's ever been made
that final choice I was there for like
yeah what I'm gonna do yeah I ain't go
live man I made that choice in like 15
seconds
like here's the thing oh it's spoiler
alert I didn't care about that town
dude what about the dogs
forget that man
I didn't spend the whole game with the
the town if anything that town was was
pretty was pretty shady to me the whole
game yeah it was it was I got rid of
town too
is highly underrated I remember when
that game started with that roof scene
and yeah based on if you was paying
attention and if you knew what was going
on the fate of somebody was in your
hands and that was crazy so I was like
yeah this game is doing something
different and it works you for taking
your time yes yes music was fantastic
the little notes a little bit really
really underrated game
um favorite console of all time Stevie
Ray and why
oh the 360 man
360. they said the games were fire uh
again they met Amber on there and I have
some lifelong friends that I still talk
to this day yeah Xbox 360. I love those
toxic dudes
wow Xbox Live days baby though oh Wild
West Lord you couldn't be you couldn't
be soft on though
you drink faucet water yeah
it was wow I kind of I kind of I love
and I love and hate the party chat
awesome because it got rid of it it got
rid of that and to your point only a few
gigs I remember was Call of Duty story
like when you played it it told you you
had the disable party chat to get it if
you had to listen to these two
yes to be honest with you like the world
today would they wouldn't they would
survive they would survive these kids
these kids ain't built for that like to
be honest with you I don't know how I
survived it yeah
was something different
yeah it's like everybody could play in
their fun little space because you in
party chat all the time with your
personal so like and I get it from a
privacy and a comfort I get that but if
you're in a situation where you forced
I'm thinking about KP I don't even think
about Halo 2 procs
somebody bodied you and you heard what
they said after that
bro one dude ran past me was like I know
you eat chicken oh wow
top five video games and franchises of
all time your personal fate
um Halo oh Horse let's go on let's go
um
uh GTA
[Music]
yeah that's right made me start getting
PlayStations which one which is your
favorite GTA San Andreas there we go
that was quick whoa
[Music]
whoa shout out to fix that pillow let's
go to crew now respawn but formerly
Infinity Ward the goats at the time
salute to Wolf yeah uh Gears of War yeah
when I seen that I was just like I've
never seen nothing like that I was
trying to educate Mr Maddie plays
because we had a section I gotta
interrupt for a second we had a section
called keep the delete or something
reboot and his it was like gears Halo
and I forgot what a Fallout was a
franchise and he's like he gonna delete
gears from the history oh no I said you
too young to understand what gears meant
and guess I'm coming for you Manny on
IOP
um you want to understand because I said
well first of all let's see what's the
three games you had to it was it was
keep delete or reboot
um keep meaning that the franchise ends
though at the point you keep it okay
delete means it's a race forever from
existence and reboot means like yo you
just give it to somebody else to make
okay from now on so he part of his
choice for his delete from existence was
he was geared but what was the three
games though Fallout Halo and gears
I'm a huge I'm gonna be honest with you
I'm a huge Fallout fan like I love the
Fallout franchise but Halo and gears has
done more for the industry whatever
dream of doing and trust me I love
Fuller the reason why I said Fallout is
because I said let's be real before
three and four nobody was playing them
older in Exile top over four years so if
you look at the series as a whole bias
aside it can't really mess with change
the game like I think I think the reason
I feel that way is because there was
still a Skyrim like the Elder Scrolls
franchise and I feel like if Fallout
wouldn't have been there they would have
took something else to the Wasteland
like it didn't have to be fall out like
I don't see anyone else making a gears
like game or a Halo like game at that
time that was like the only thing out
there like that like look Fallout is it
is a unique type of game but at the end
of the day it is the Bethesda formula
that they could have done with another
Wasteland game right all I would say
would get so we'll get it back to KP was
that when it came out for its time the
graphic Fidelity Cliff position that
team put in that's a poll question that
was yeah that actually should be a
problem
that was that made people go yo what is
that that is the most and then it was
the commercial made them do that in the
market then they had the iconic we've
never seen a gun like that when you rev
up what
what
the viciousness and you just
eviscerating people so like then they
gave us hard mode but I'm glad you said
yes because gears got to get his flowers
so that that's what I wanted so she's
okay so you got the kids we got the GTA
we got the Halo what was up yeah oh yeah
I think alone one more right I struggle
flip-flopping between these two Sava
appreciates it oh I'm gonna have to go
with red dead
my last one which one red dead one or
just two which one the the first one
okay Red Dead Redemption
okay you could have came back but now
that's what didn't mean this this shows
that you're an elevated individual
you look you look you're looking down
upon the piano attitude
no Okay cool so we I think that was five
right that was five yeah that's five all
right and then favorite console of all
time and what
shout out to Peter Moore you appreciate
this yeah
oh
the 360
. yeah God on the belly lost already
okay
let's go all right so the polls in the
chat keep in mind this poll is
representative on if that franchise
leaves anything it inspired after that
is gone as well like it's out of
existence it's not like we know it that
game doesn't exist
that was that was five man dip down yo
y'all know y'all games addict put the
joint in the chat man let's do some love
to dip down okay yeah oh oh you're
talking about yeah they put the twin is
it you know what I'm saying put the
Twitter up in there put the YouTube in
there well I I've been putting I've been
putting it there in the whole show there
you go there we go put that dip down go
subscribe to the channel tell them iops
I did already no doubt dip down anime no
doubt and then put the YouTube channel
if you can um Stevie Ray so you can have
the direct link for that yeah put that
up in there you know what I'm saying and
then what we should do Attic in the
future I like those um he said why
addicts for the difference
try to influence on the poem
I just wanted you guys to know the rules
of engagement
anyway so
it's a match tremendous we got these
topics all this fun stuff we're gonna
get these super chats off and then I get
to pull bet no doubt we have
the
couple
Raiden blade remember for one year two
pound Super Chat Christopher Hart if you
get into a game in 30 seconds or less
hot fire I guess
then we got bean dip nip slip
shout out to me okay two dollars shout
out to King and the Xbox crew podcast
kicking them kicking them podcasts
another two dollar Super Chat from bean
dip nip slip
yes shout out to Christopher Hart's
chilling for PlayStation
and then we have Max AKA The Lazy otaku
five dollars per chat if you were born
after 2003 or 04 you wasn't surviving
them 360 COD lobbies or party chat not
up for the debate shout out late night
party chats yeah
Different Cloth man at home man
caught up yes let's get this poll going
on last week's four results to end the
people spoken with Sony's latest
statement regarding Xbox Call of Duty
offer staying on PlayStation 3 years and
the current agreement ending being
inadequate what do you feel Microsoft's
response should be the winner of a close
four-way IOP poll at 44 in the vote was
stand your ground Microsoft should tell
Sony three years only take it or leave
it coming in at second very close 31 of
the vote because despiteful Lords next
to deal with sodium PlayStation Call of
Duty Arrangement agreement ends make
game pass the exclusive home of Call of
Duty
in third place at 12 was the negotiation
laws they will like extend Call of Duty
all for past three years to maintain the
relationship with Sony until all the
PlayStation dudes
please don't take it away
and in last place 11 of the vote was the
messy Lord's Auto Care switch still
coming in hot with Call of Duty not on
their platform Lord Sovereign your
thoughts on the poll they what they what
Microsoft stand they
grounded
stay quiet you know what I mean be quiet
for right now you know the fed's still
watching you know what I'm saying well
why I just be quiet be like okay cool
understand their concerns and this that
the other as soon as the deal goes
through you say three
the truth of the matter is is what Phil
said
unless
if Jim Ryan literally has these these
recording conversations like they have
behind closed doors they're like no
don't act like you didn't say this bill
for sure and you just said I could just
see in the courtrooms it's just like I
never said that he just plays a button
and has Phil saying that you're trying
to say this 50 Cent
50 record conversations
listen end of the day is this like
unless they plan to change the release
Cadence for Call of Duty or what Call of
Duty is fundamentally it's a dumb
business move to take that off of
PlayStation they're gonna figure that
out they're gonna figure it out and
they're gonna figure it out probably
three years at a time that doesn't make
any you know yeah that's just Jim trying
to trying to get into bed for 10 years
at a time and it's not gonna happen
that's not gonna happen so that's it
cool let's get into these topics
everybody has been waiting for let's
kick it off with King's topic I'll set
it up from 343 departures y'all a lot of
the uh developments this week kind of
broke the internet on Bonnie Ross and
also David Berger reported by our very
own Lords of gaming.net next shout out
to uh Nicholas Downey put that out there
shout out to on Windows Central giving
us the love kind of funny giving us the
love and of course Brad Sims giving us a
little owner sourcing Lords of
gaming.net go check that out great
articles up there gotta promote the
whole team because we did a whole yes
sir you know what I'm saying we did our
homework and we're getting the love but
um yeah we got to talk about it at all
pretty much the statement again was
released I believe the 12th I believe is
Monday was when it when it broke and um
yeah it pretty much saw Bonnie Ross
founder and head of our 343 Studios put
this statement out while I hope to stay
with Halo until we release the winter
update I'm letting you know I'll be
leaving 343 and attending to a family
medical issue I am incredibly proud of
the work everyone at 343 Industries has
done with handle infinite the Master
Chief Collection the Halo TV series and
so much more it's been an honor to serve
alongside the team for the last 15 years
and to be part of the universe that I
love thank you everyone in the Halo
Community for your support Halo's future
it's bright I cannot wait for all of you
to experience what we have in store and
to cheer alongside you as a fan as the
Halo World Championship in October and
then obviously with our report with the
follow-up with Lords gaming.net go check
that out
um yeah big changes looks like we have
obviously we had a source to collaborate
that David Berger director of
engineering at 343 has also departed
also David Berger he led development on
the Halo infinite slip space engine and
he also um like I said he comes from
again a big background we wanted besides
Chris Lee that left before that but yeah
he was another kind of integral part to
Halo infinite so King I don't know if
you want to set it off with with you and
your feelings on this situation
all right so
let's put a face to the person
all right that's Bonnie Ross
so a lot of you dudes probably don't
know what she looked like
that's a fact
a lot of y'all probably never had the
opportunity to talk to him
now I've talked to her in like 2017-18
she was a night she was nice very nice
person
I've said in the past
because heavy is the head that where's
the crown right you're the head of the
studio and if the studio is having bad
times and you know of course they're
gonna to look to that individual and if
something has to happen it usually rolls
down hell first right and we've we've
said it in the past if um
if anything had to happen you know
unfortunately
right right well first of all we're
going to take out a word that it was a
family issue we're going to give her
that respect what I did not like was I
saw my peers and I'm not talking about
Twitter dudes Twitter dude Yola trolls
y'all are idiots y'all yeah some people
are taking it way too far yeah yo y'all
that's definitely
um
y'all have no remorse these are human
beings so but I'm talking about my peers
I saw a lot of my peers give backhanded
uh compliments uh snide little remarks
you're kick in an individual when
they're down
regardless to how you feel you got your
pound of Flesh
you didn't need to say anything more
she took up the mantle to become head of
343. I loved Bungie's Halo games I
really like 343 uh Halo games and I
wanted them to be I wanted them to rival
Bungie's Halo games and I think that um
they had the opportunity to do that but
I I think a lot of times too much stuff
was thrown on a plate and everything was
expanding as we got a chance to look and
understand what was going on under the
hood we realized that they were under
tremendous amounts of stress
stuff was being changed engines was
being changed a lot of workers weren't
there for a period of Time new workers
were coming in so you have to get the
new workers up to speed then you also
had to deal with a pandemic and not to
mention all the contractors too that's
that's what I'm talking about the
contractors that was there that left and
then you have to get those new workers
up to speed to what these workers was
doing it's it was an absolute mess and
and to put it all on one person to to
aim your vitriol to one person and to
act like this because of one person this
happens like this no that spreads all
across but not one time did she throw
anybody under the bus now one time did
she point out anybody at all
she took everything head-on 100 with
class and walked out the door with class
she's an Xbox life but she did not want
to leave the Halo situation like it is
she wanted it to be finished she once
she started the fight she wanted to
finish the fight she's a Spartan doing
through 100 percent
and you're gonna give her the respect of
a Spartan you dudes are you're flimsy
with it you're sometimes with it
and and I just really can't respect it I
got to give a shout out to one of my
friends that he posted something and I
said that is of bad taste please take it
down and he did promptly respect
because I respect the individuals I
respect the people as you get more
educated on what's going on
then you realize these are humans just
with a job and they're trying to do the
best job they possibly can no one is
trying to sink any franchise
they're trying to do their best their
name is attached to this
so y'all are behind keyboards
anonymously
being rude being disrespectful
to somebody that has feelings and
emotions
and I'm just saying
Sometimes the best things to say if you
don't have anything nice to say is
nothing at all you could have said thank
you for all the stuff that you did thank
you for all the wonderful memories and
if you don't have nothing nice to say
just don't just do not press send I was
just really hurt that day and I sat down
and I was like damn
how does it feel to be her at this
moment
and it was just rude and disrespectful
and I'm just talking to my peers yeah I
know where you go I know you're going I
don't care about the Twitter people and
let's be clear you know um she's a
legend in the space yes you know we we
we we understand the frustration with
the franchise I'm jumping for a second
out of turn I'm finished but um yeah
like at the end of the day you know she
is responsible for keeping Halo alive
after you know saying yeah the the
bungee thing and um we have to be
respectful we understand the resume we
understand everything that has gone on
with the franchise no one's minimizing
that and no one's saying no one should
be held accountable as the face but
let's be let's give the whole picture
right and I understand when you're
coming so the salute to you on that you
know I think that needed to be said you
know at the end of the day it's a human
being it's a job and it also goes to
show you after the departure how the
role was split yeah
she was doing one job you're doing the
job of three different people facts
nobody's taking that into account right
so now that goes to show you this blame
across the board right because if one
person is that now and they leave exit
or whatever has to do three jobs there's
a lot of blame to be going why is that
one person have all this responsibility
to begin with right and why is this play
but we're gonna get into it okay I'm
glad you said that because I needed to
be said just on a human level you know
what I mean we want to be respectful
let's get the dip down first um let's
get you Stevie Ray when the news broke
you know obviously Bonnie Ross David
Berger you know Twitter's been in the
frenzy a lot of people want Halo to
improve now that the dust is settled how
are you feeling when the new or when the
news broke or just what was your thought
process
oh yeah man I was definitely shocked the
only person I did was text KP I was like
man this is for real you know like it's
crazy I mean I don't uh Crooks went
wrong but I don't think like a lot of
people understand that Bonnie Ross the
big part with like Phil Spencer keeping
you know Xbox afloat when they were
struggling doing Xbox One at times you
know and Microsoft was thinking about
cutting them yeah yeah hey what a Halo
yeah they were like why are we in gaming
why are we spending all this that's a
good point exactly so I mean you know
the conversation that happens you know
we might not be having this conversation
so yeah I mean I think she had a lot on
her you know uh you know between the
video games she was helping on a TV show
she was doing the media products uh they
were just a lot going on and you know I
think you know King said it best you
know uh she is uh gonna take care of her
family and she's going to do what she
needs to do to better herself in her
situation and uh I think we just respect
that you know yeah and disrespect what
she did you know she's a pillar yeah I
respect that KP where where you at with
the Halo news and overall now that the
news broke out on the really the I'm
sorry I'd even mentioned I forgot to
mention instead King up even better was
that
um on the top level shake-up after her
departure so now Pierre hints will
replace Bonnie as the new head of 343
um Brian Koski is the new general
manager of the franchise and Elizabeth
Van Wyck is the new Overseer of business
and operations and those were asking I
know there was a lot of um talk about
Joseph Staton he looks like he's going
to remain in his role as far as creative
but these are the three people now
that's kind of been taking these
positions moving forward so KP any news
I mean any thoughts on this news
breaking for you yeah when I seen that I
got slightly nervous because I thought
something bad happened to her and then I
read it and I was like oh that's
unfortunate that she has to leave one of
those circumstances yeah you know you
hate to see anybody have to leave on
something like that yeah um
you know I I liked her I like what she
was doing I don't think nothing was
ultimately wrong with the Halo games
that she's done I mean they performed
and played well and people just don't
like the story I think people hold Halo
up to the stands of like Star Wars it
gets treated the same way you know like
nothing's better than the first three
yeah it's her fault you know which I
thought they were fine they're trying to
move it forward you know she actually
saved it and I think she was just spread
too thin as well it's possible you know
as we can see you know now and these
things probably been going in motion
since probably stating was um aborted
back to your team yeah but I hope she
bounces back and whoever you know in her
family uh does well you know in good
health yeah not fair enough fair enough
Lord addict man this is a big one we're
very passionate about this franchise I
know you're extremely passionate about
it the news broke where you're at with
the situation at 3.3
I think
here's the thing do I think Bonnie
needed to eventually step down yes but I
think it's unfair to put all of the
blame on Bonnie Ross I think there's a
lot of variables that's led to the Halo
franchise where it's at now and I think
I don't think Bonnie's the biggest
variable if anything what I have been
told is there you know the slip space
engine is hard to develop on right now
you know there's a lot of things that's
really related to what's going on I
don't think that I think that's what's
wrong look why I'm trying to have a word
from what about the things we know yeah
I'm trying to be careful what I say here
I think that development Freedom
sometimes wasn't wasn't kept realistic
during the development you know I think
people wanted to be ambitious a little
bit too ambitious with the Halo
franchise and by the time they realize
and check themselves at the door on what
was available able to do it in a timely
manner it was already too late so that
we don't
um there's a term called scope creep
yeah right and it's like where things
keep getting added and added and added
and then you may have to go up I can
talk about Brad Samson so you know you
know so like now it's like okay well now
we're gonna do Overworld but now we're
gonna do this and now we're gonna do
that and then now you have to keep
coming back to Microsoft and asking for
more bread and and that is returning
investment involved right because it's
like okay now this game got to come out
we done game this money but as far as
your point like do you think the game
started just becoming too ambitious is
that what you're kind of implying well I
don't want people it's not that it was
too ambitious they didn't lock stuff
down on what they wanted in the real
game yeah so when you have like this big
giant pie and you keep adding on to it
the the codes in the middle you're not
cooking the other sides of the pie
you're just cook in the middle so it's
just like there's a lot of factors that
led to what it was it too I I know for a
fact that some of the Reddit uh leaks
are true I'm not going to tell you guys
which ones but some of those write it
looks true where you know they they was
certain game modes that was all the way
up to damn near the to the launch of the
game that was just scrapped at the last
minute so it's just like look
uh I hate that Bonnie had to leave on
such uh horrible conditions I hope her
family's good uh you know I hope
everything works out there you know as
far as the three people that took her
place I hope they do that job uh you
know as a as a group as a unit better uh
and it's just like look like you know I
another thing I know people ain't gonna
like this but you know Phil Spencer and
Matt booty and them they got to take
some of the blame on hey Lewis too
because they're the ones that report
that she reported to so it's just like
look like Halo infinite is in the
direction it is because of management uh
and my thing is like
you could sit there and you can deny and
you can what's what I'm looking for
try to
take this scenario that she's leaving
regardless if she left for medical
reasons or she's using that to leave
it's irrelevant to the situation uh it
doesn't matter why she left she's gone
it doesn't matter if it was medical it
doesn't matter if you know that that's
the term that they're using she's gone
so it's just like to me
what is bringing up trying to say that
she's lying about medical going to do to
the situation absolutely zero and I feel
like it's mad disrespectful like you
know it's one thing to speak your
opinion on nothing it's another thing to
say that someone's lying about leaving
for medical reasons no I think my job is
real quick because I I do still some
things on this part but
the medical thing for my yeah it's
clearly there's there's reality to that
no one's Trying to minimize that no
one's trying to disrespect that what I
do know is that the timing is
interesting and the reason why I have to
say that is that at the end of the day
we're talking about a legend here a
legend at Microsoft this is a person
with extreme cache
and you when you have that level you
can't publicly humiliate that person my
foreign
you just can't it's it's it's it's the
public PR aspect of it so whether they
how they chose to handle it and I would
get up not saying anyone is lying all
I'm saying is the timing is different
because incorporate you know what I'm
saying it's it's just it's it's a
visibility it's the way things look and
at the end of the day here's my thing
like someone had to make the call
right and from what I hear
on the Microsoft side
there are people like she has a very
strong contingency she's you know pretty
much almost like a life right so it's
like there's gonna be a lot of people in
that building that are not happy with
the call on the Microsoft Microsoft side
what we do know on the three four three
side for what we can talk about
is that there were people that felt that
regime
was holding things back for whatever
reason whether it was overworked didn't
have the resources things wasn't getting
communicated to the top
so there's the conflict right me
personally I'm just gonna jump in if you
don't mind I'm sorry I got a lot to say
no I'm sorry soft I'm sorry I got a lot
of things because um the thing is lava
at the end of the day right someone has
to make the call and the thought process
was Microsoft's hands off let the
studios do what they want to do and you
know that's just how it is but what
we're seeing is there is repercussions
here there are repercussions if if
deliverables are not made return on
investment is not me things of that
nature is not me and at the end of the
day regardless of the Legacy or what
have you
Halo 4 Halo 5 and infinite separately
had issues right and from what we hear
infinite just to get it out the door
was an issue because we all agree the
base was was called it was pure was
great right but it just didn't have the
content to keep going on for a live
service model that that's really what
the issue was that the game wasn't good
the single player was solid the
multiplayer was amazing we was out here
popping bottles the king is back right
it's just that we like damn where's the
content so what did you show you just to
get it over the Finish Line was just so
hard you know what I mean and at the end
of the day like King said we're not
solely blaming one person but at the end
of the day what's the what's the what's
the term heavy is the head right heavy
is the head that way the crown that
that's how I was going it doesn't matter
what is this that's how it is in sports
you go it don't matter the defense blew
the game they gonna look at the
quarterback you know it don't matter if
someone fun with the ball running back
they gonna look at the quarterback so I
think that's you know some of the things
that we're seeing and we're hearing
that's going on here and look you know
again I'll just jump in like my thing is
at the end of the day it's being split
up into this three-headed type of
situation which shows you the role of of
bonding all things kind of she had to
deal with I want to shout out Pierre
Hintz you know he's one of the main
people who helped turn Master Chief
Collection completely around
right so that to me is a good sign you
know I'm saying that okay this is a
person that is going to have there
they're gonna have two other people
that's going to deal with the high level
stuff where the franchise goals all that
all that good stuff so look we just got
to see what happens I personally like
that state in the staying in Creative he
doesn't have to deal with the top level
stuff this is a person that's the
surveyor of Halo 2 Halo 3 the things
that people realize ought to feel that
all the greatest Halos and wrote those
you know he's in a good position there
and it allows him to you know Flex his
credible she's bringing bungee people in
we have to see all I will say is that
these changes don't expect this day to
turn around extremely quickly this is
gonna take time this is going to take
time this might take a year before you
see the effects of said change you know
what I'm saying kind of thing but I
think ultimately if you're going to put
a gun in my head at the end of the day
I think for the long term thing of a
future of the franchise maybe it's the
right call because at the end of the day
they've got a fixed cost what was
happening was what was going on just
wasn't working currently it just wasn't
working and maybe they can meet these
deliverables and meet get the tooling
and get all the live service model and I
want Halo to see it's my favorite I
don't like to see Halo like this I don't
you know I want this thing to be the
greatest things this is what got me one
of the things got me in the game KP was
talking about you know I'm saying Halo
how important it is to him I read this
system link in the crib like this is
Halo me everything to me like Halo got
me in the first person shooters you know
I mean so all I want
take your time fix the back end stuff
Forge is coming what you call a co-ops
coming in November but I want take your
time do that meaty taking King type
comeback where you give PVE PVP maybe
the Battle Royal is ready at the time
and drop a major expansion to
reinvigorate this joint and like
anything else live service can come back
like one thing about lives if you do it
right live service can come back so
that's all I got to say I'm sorry I had
to jump because attic was saying some
stuff you know let you finish and I I
have truly done on this but I will let
you and then soft get it get your bars
off it's like I said you know it's like
Cog said uh I do feel like regardless if
whoever was fought for what Halo
infinite is with right now there's been
enough time especially with three games
that is just like you know sooner or
later the other part of the pendulum's
gonna swing and you know I personally
don't want no one to like you know lose
their job leave on their own terms or
anything related to that I want what's
best for Halo and you know if if this
management change helps do that then I'm
all for it it's just you know I think
the best thing to
to come out from this and I think the
best thing for the people in the chat I
know a lot about what's going on with
343 and I'm telling you right now Bonnie
Ross wasn't solely responsible for Halo
infinite's uh the the condition it is
like she definitely didn't help it but I
don't think people realize that there
was a lot of variables because the
moment that was announced that's all I
saw uh you know what according to
Twitter the day that she announced that
she's resigning
is now Halo's fixed yes back is lit
that's not the case there's a lot of
things that's going to happen
there's a lot of things that need to
happen with the Halo franchise before it
is back where it needs to be and keep in
mind it's going to take years for this
franchise to get back to where it needs
to be and that's if it ever does I don't
honestly think that Halo could ever be
on top like it used to I think back in
the day it was the reason it was so
dominant is because there wasn't a lot
of competition I don't think that
I think it could be competitive but I
don't think it could be
on top anymore uh because you got
fortnite over there doing what fortnite
does you got Apex Legend dude with Apex
plus there's a lot more
a lot more competition I mean Call of
Duty isn't even a fraction of its size
that it used to be because these other
franchises are so dominant but
I do believe that Halo can be
competitive it's just got to get the
[ __ ] rolling in the right direction
hopefully this leads to that direction I
don't know if it will uh like I said
there's a lot of mother stuff oh yeah
but hopefully we could see some
improvements in the next like six months
and to your point before you just saw I
was also you know we're not going to act
like when it came out it dominated the
Steve charts it was killing Xbox Live
it's just that as the weeks went on and
you started to realize there was no one
content coming it's that's when the and
then the PC issues clearly you know what
I'm saying it's not easy to do a games
as a service and I think I think people
get this weird concept that it is uh
games as a service probably the hardest
one of the hardest things you can do
yeah and you know Microsoft's been
trying to do it for a while look what we
see thieves came out when it started
yeah you know and slowly they started
getting everything they needed and set
and they got the millions
and you know
throughout throughout time they've been
able to fix that franchise and I think
that would do the same thing with fatal
infinite I honestly and truly do now we
can have a debate on whether or not not
they should you know go ahead and cut
their ties with fatal infinite and
finish supporting it while they make a
new Halo because sometimes the best
thing to do to fix a brand is to have a
newer game you know that's debatable if
they do that I don't know if they're
going to do that but you know I I think
this is good for the Halo franchise I
don't think that people should be going
on there blaming one person for the
entire entity of Halo infinite but I do
think that you know it
I think that people are entitled to
their opinion one thing I will say is
people
need to stop saying that you need to do
something to be able to criticize it and
I I'm that's one thing I am getting
frustrated with because if I go to if I
go to a restaurant and they start to be
burnt food four or five times I've never
cooked in that restaurant but I can tell
you something's up with that man
so it's just like you know you can get
like you but here's the thing like I
think the biggest issue that people have
is making definitive answers like they
know how to do like they know every and
they know everything
especially people on this podcast we we
never do that we all I mean I'm famous
for saying y'all don't know nothing
about that Tech stuff uh that's up to
you guys uh and I think that we need to
be better on not only trying to act like
we know how to develop a full-blown game
like it's just it's just click a button
but we also needed to be better on
trying to silence other people's
opinions on criticism especially when
it's valid that's the biggest thing not
for you soft sorry job hijacked you spot
no it's fine it doesn't matter there's
no there's no set order here whatever
works what's your thoughts on this man I
think first and foremost everybody needs
to acknowledge that Halo doesn't exist
in the without Bonnie Ross it just
doesn't
when Bungie finished Halo 3
the thinking was
right afterwards they left right they
went on to make reach but that was
contractually obligated still but they
were gone by the time they finished
reach they were gone for three years by
the time reach came out
the thinking at Microsoft was hey
either we end the Master Chief story
completely right or if the or if the
franchise moves forward we give it the
gearbox that made the PC port for Combat
Evolved we give it to gearbox for a
couple of games
and then we'll be done with it right and
it was Bonnie that said no yeah much
like everyone's saying now this is your
Flagship title how are you going to kill
it yeah how would you how are you just
going to kill it no she fought to keep
it alive there's no doubt and she
pitched her vision for Halo to Shane Kim
at the time
and they form 343 what would become
three four three and you have held out
so a lot of people that you know again
all the comments and stuff like that
that don't need to be said remember
there's no Halo without body rubs um
none there just isn't because Microsoft
if they're making business like
decisions and if the daddy of the child
is left maybe the thinking is what we're
not going to give it to anybody else we
just kill it and leave on top and that's
it right so looking at the situation
when you look at Bonnie's statement
it's obvious to me that this was planned
for for a while already her departure
was planned already for a while yeah I
actually personally feel like she she
hasn't been present for probably six
months right yeah whatever the case may
be whether she has or hasn't been
present the departure TV show that's
probably the last thing she was like
directly hands on with yeah
um obviously the family situation
made it made made her exit swifter right
it had to be more immediate than that
but I think the decision was made a long
time ago and when you think about going
back to what you guys said about how her
role was split into three roles it is
obvious that she had way too much on her
plate and when you want to look at
issues with management that cause a game
to sort of continually continuously
stutter step and not meet its
deliverables and its goals if at the top
of the food chain there are issues with
things with too many things being
juggled and too many hats being worn
it's going to trickle down and you're
going to see this again us from the
outside we're speculating we're seeing
it we're assuming right and now we
finally get some confirmation of what's
been happening right because you could
say bad management bad management bad
management I know what the hell you're
talking about and you don't know the
details of what that means right here
it's obvious that she was wearing a lot
of hats and for you to be able to juggle
all of that and the products stay on
course it's a hard thing for things to
be kind of crazy at the top and for the
bottom to be functioning perfectly it
doesn't happen that way right it just
doesn't happen that way so at the end of
the day ultimately when I look at
Bonnie's departure yes do I think it
needed to happen yes but I think that
for this reason even the greatest
leaders who have been with a product or
a company for the longest time what
starts to happen after a while is that
you're too close to it you're too close
to it to truly look at it objectively
even if you have the best intentions to
do so right you can't step back from it
because it you eat sleep it every day
right you can't step back from it in the
in the most objective of ways and look
at your baby with a harsh eye and say
okay what really needs to be done to fix
this especially when you love the
influence in the building too exactly
right so it's a very difficult thing to
do and so I I commend Bonnie because
again the family situation
notwithstanding which I think you know
just again expedited her exit I think
she made this decision a long time ago
as I'm going to take the I'm going to
take the L on this and walk away as the
leader of this and allow other people
leadership she realized like look
regardless if everything's not my fault
I am the re the captain at this [ __ ] so
it's just and it falls on me regardless
to how it really breaks down it falls on
me and I think ultimately that is the
smart thing now you have an opportunity
to step back and reassess how everything
is being done in regards to Halo and try
to get it to where it needs to be and as
an outside Observer and someone who
loves Halo who was excited at the
prospect of it being a a service based
game when I say okay how do you make it
compete with what's out there now yeah
you turn for you to play multiplayer you
turn it into this service based game at
the end of the day looking at it you
know a year out from its original launch
and seeing the Cadence of release and
stuff like that unless the willingness
is there to put the amount of money and
effort and resources behind it that uh
that an apex has or that uh a
Whatchamacallit a fortnight has if that
willingness is not there then to me the
best thing to do is support this game as
far as you're willing to take it and
then go back to making a Halo I'm okay
with Halo going back to getting a new
Halo game every four or five years
making it a closed product right you
have your single player and then you
have your multiplayer which you support
with map packs for however you want to
do and you make it a contained
experience again a quality experience
and you forget about making it this
Grand thing because I agree with at it
it's very hard to put it back at the
Pinnacle where it was and I would argue
that this already started to happen in
2007 when Halo 3 came out everybody
thought it was the greatest thing in the
world but there was a but there was a
caveat months before we got Call of Duty
4 which changed the game completely and
it changed the Paradigm it's like what
did the Rocks say the the the the
hierarchy of power chains a little bit
that changed it it really did change it
really did change how we started yeah
we got Halo 3 after that in November
right yeah and it was amazing yeah but
it was still like whoa there's still
this other thing and so to me
this is the way I love Halo I love Halo
and I and I love a lot of the direction
they took with it with this but if there
is not the understanding that you need
to do X Y and Z with it to make it
successful as a service-based product or
go back to making it a singular product
and and and give us quality games in
that regard and I think we're good but
again at the end of the day the Bonnie
situation to me I think her as a leader
I think that's a decision she made and
was allowed to make of her own accord
I think she made the right move just for
her own health because again no matter
how much you love something you can be
too close to it you can be and salute to
Xbox also because whoever made the
decision the talk was they would never
you know XBox doesn't manage any that's
the problem they're so hands-off
remember that was the talk that they
would never do anything so to me this
put I'm not gonna say look no one
personally finds a good thing but I'm
saying overall look if the Liberals
aren't made they're showing you there
are repercussions regardless of what
your statue is so now everyone else is
on notice right you see what I'm saying
what change can happen it don't matter
you the studio you don't have that blah
blah blah you it could happen right so
so that should at least alleviate that
talk and I want to respect whatever
because that couldn't have been easy
that could not have been easy there's no
way you telling me that could be easy
addict get your balls on I'm sorry
I actually felt like the best move for
Halo infinite yeah well Halo in general
is to do what Call of Duty and war zone
are doing to separate the campaign with
the with the multiplayer I actually feel
like I have been team hundred percent
that that Halo needs a battle royale
because that's what the majority of the
younger audience is playing and I could
look you look what you're at fortnite
right now you know you have the thing
where you could just do the team death
match over and over again King remember
we were doing it yeah then you have the
the basic fortnite where you could just
play with buildings then you have the
non-building mode it's just like you
could have done all of that in one game
but you know it's just like look arena
is you know that standard Arena type
shooting stuff it still has a following
but it's not popular anymore
and it's just like you know I feel like
especially with the iconic areas that
that
Halo has access to reach you know that
they they got they can make a map with
high charity because it's so big like
it's just like I personally feel like
you know you get the Battle Royale with
the arena add-on where people can still
play their Arena add-on and that's a
separate thing that's being co-developed
uh you know people are helping with that
34 3 is helping with that and then you
have this team of like a hundred people
just cranking out a Halo campaign and
then it's like you know with Call of
Duty they have when the new campaign to
Halo comes out in a couple years when
you buy it you get stuff for the
multiplayer and then you just keep
recycling this but it's just like I
personally feel like
they should put the boots the the they
should put the gloves up I I think 343
should be let them do their own thing
because at this point it's like you know
what they've been doing in a decade I
would love to see them be allowed to
make something let me make something
else I would like personally I don't
mind if they stay with it but I mean me
personally I would like just also some
spin-off games in this amazing universe
that they have yeah you know what I'm
saying because you've got the Arbiter
you've got a lot you've got stories to
tell yes you don't necessarily have to
keep everything in an FPS thing and Halo
could be the Mainstay and they could go
away for a little bit you know what I'm
saying and then you can continue these
stories that this greater universe that
they've got they've got all this
opportunity so look and the other thing
too okay I was gonna say I've been a
very big open person I think you know
just to just to mix stuff up let like
Coalition make a Halo game and let uh
hey uh 343 make a gears game
the only reason I'm not like a third
person like a third person action
adventure like Halo game where you're
like the Army
yeah
I don't know what I don't know what
three four three would do with uh with
the gear franchise you know how
acrobatic the Arbiter actually should be
you know what I mean like I mean we got
to be clear though with the with this
studio thing I know everybody that's the
talk you know give somebody else a dream
but we got to remember this is a custom
engine that they made the engine they
say unreal they say like a joint you
could just pass off and they've got all
this history with it so it's not that
easy to be like yo take the slip strip
space and you go do something you know
like it's it's tough it's tough so
they're in they're in a different thing
and my feeling is and I'll give it back
to you at it is that I rather stay in
and the creatives that had this game at
the Pinnacle at the Apex be given the
chance to do it their way and then let's
see what happened now if it don't go
down after that
then I'm hoping for whatever you know
what I'm saying but I I personally know
that man got off his couch because he
didn't like what was going on that man
wrote Halo 2 that man is bringing in X
Bungie plus people who had this
franchise at its greatest I would like
to see him got the opportunity and I
would like Pierre them to have an
opportunity I'm not me personally I'm
not what I get it you know what I'm
saying and I'm not saying it's wrong to
think that because look some people
gonna say yo these games ate the four
five and eight if it ain't been good
someone else get a shot I understand I
can't really dispute you on that all I'm
saying is I just like what's in place
based on the history and what their
track record says and I want to give
them a shot that's all let me clarify
some stuff I see in the chat no I want
college to make a third person action
adventure I don't want them doing it
first person second off I keep people's
I keep seeing people say let someone
else make Halo who ID why won't people
put one in the chat if you played the
multiplayer I bet you if you ain't
Captain there's not a lot of ones in
that chat
well you like people act like Halo was
such an easy product that anyone can
pick up and do I agree Halo is probably
one of the most complex things you can
do right now in this gaming industry it
is one of the few franchises that people
expect a solid multiplayer and a solid
single player it's one of the few
franchises that you know regardless if
you do games as a service that's going
to be hard on its own I mean I I
honestly think you could probably let
another Studio make them the campaign
section of it but as far as like doing
both like people don't realize how many
people's working on Halo yeah it is an
absurd amount of people yeah they got
probably a thousand plus people at the
Pinnacle of making Halo infinite during
the pandemic people act like any any
student could just pick up yeah pick up
that development like that yeah and what
a lot of people don't realize either is
that you know you got Gamers sometimes
don't look in the mirror and see see how
they the things that they say right you
say this like someone or not say you
someone says this right okay get ready
to get get them out of there no one is
going to make the Halo game that you
want other than 343 it's going to be
different it's going to feel different
and immediately there's going to be
backlash so
I mean what are you asking for and I've
said and I'm the first one I say it blow
everything up no I think I'm sorry yeah
exactly but again I I'm willing to see
the end result to that a lot of a lot of
Hardcore Halo fans you know like if you
you touched their Halo it's a problem
the problem with this is when it comes
to the Halo franchise it's not easy to
replace that it's not easy to have
someone come in there and do that Halo
you got people that love the Lord you
got people that love the the feeling of
the actual game itself I would say the
only developer I lie that's in
functioning order to be able to take it
over is Bungie and look bungee's been
doing Destiny long enough where if you
think they're going to take over Halo
about incorporating some form of super
in that game I got it you know I I got
some I got some Lakes I want to sell to
you here's the funny thing everybody
capping for the destiny model and forget
we've been on the destiny trade and know
when this was in the straight bushes it
had to come back anytime like this live
service thing is not easy bro
I think it was almost dead from the jump
people forget and what's funny is like
people sit there you know that's one of
the things that I feel like hey about
PlayStation has been able to really
identify we don't want no smoke with
that games as a service until recently
we don't want no smoke with that we go
with making our you know designated uh
you know third person action of venture
gains because we are used to that and it
doesn't require a lot of work after the
game is developed like it takes
a huge team to keep up that kind of that
kind of flowing I personally feel like
343 can do it but it's just like
there's a lot of stuff that I wish I
could say about it okay
oh okay the core though we got to say
this as much as we go down we're going
to stop alone I'm gonna get right back
to you we gotta admit though as much as
we going in
the core Foundation of Halo infinite is
good the multiplayer is good you know
what I'm saying the story was solid the
game itself is actually good it just was
the content of the live service model so
it's this is really it's really looking
it's not I should say it's not that
difficult it theoretically this should
be able to be saved based on because
most games don't have the foundation
right yeah you know what I'm saying we
was out here like yo it is back we saw
that we saw our stream on the reaction
with it with the repulsors and all the
stuff going on and it's one of the most
creative sandboxes in gaming the things
that can happen in this sandbox no other
game is doing period like we're not
gonna be disrespectful to what was
actually placed the question came down
to where is the content as the months
went on we like damn the emperor ain't
got no clothes where's the rest of the
gear at like where's the things at like
you supposed to have had this stuff
rocket that don't come with the one map
and where's the forge of the Court
that's where it started to add up but be
clear the game is fire we are not going
to do that to Halo infinite straight up
I'm sorry now I just don't want to get
you in trouble continue go back I think
that when it comes to Halo Halo infinite
is a good Halo game it's a bad game it's
a service yes perfect and bingo the
thing is it's like it's like I said part
of the reason that it's in the condition
that it's in is because for a long time
they didn't know what that game was
going to be yeah it changed and for a
long time they kept going in and out on
if we want to do it this way if we want
to do it that way and by the time that
everyone was took to the room that's
like yo we need this game out by this
time
a lot of that stuff that has probably
was in development for from months to
years was just scrapped because it
wouldn't be finished in time yeah and
now you got this section where it's like
we got good gameplay
but they didn't have enough time to form
the games as a service on top of that
because sure Halo infinite was worked on
for probably six years but in our
actuality
that core game was probably only made in
two
it's a possibility look we beat this
thing to death we got to move on hoping
for the best you know with the changes
and shout out to Pierre shout out to the
team you know hopefully get it on track
but let's get these super chats because
we got stuff to talk about other stuff
to talk about too yeah okay hold on a
second
uh we got over 600 and only 200 and
something I liked let's go get the likes
you know hit the deadly come on let's go
come on let's get it I'm gonna have to
send you all to the bushes
[Laughter]
Phil Spencer responds to Jim y'all been
eating long enough now Stop Being Greedy
wow that's a deal that's boys
okay
there we go some Z two dollar Super Chat
was good what's good brother thank you
so much and we got splendiferous
remember for 11 months shout out to you
sir listen Phil says to Jim you let me
slap you as hard as I want or watch you
in front of all your Fanboys on Twitter
I'll give you card forever but if not
kiss the baby goodbye
the difference is don't mean them play
some streets we got some difference
again uh two dollar Super Chat thank
Bonnie Ross and her fine stuff
whoa keep your personal biases aside
there you know stay there
[Laughter]
there we go Stewie 108 10 super chat oh
thank you so much then we got bosnian09
five dollar Super Chat Bonnie Ross did
the job of three people three put some
respect on her name no doubt responding
straight up Hydra I should tell you
something after that like that's crazy
no we got hargit to me remember for one
year ten dollar Super Chat people should
remember Halo infinite was made when
Xbox was about to be shut down no
investment from Microsoft bad corporate
decisions hurt their chances she takes
some blame but not all no need for
ritual against three four three yes that
is 100 correct then we have Tai casares
15 Super Chat this is one of two thank
you uh thank you more reasonable people
when so many just acting childish the
problem we should be pointing at is
either Microsoft or Xbox why didn't Halo
get another delay or why doesn't Halo
have uh and this is number two 15 Super
Chat once again more devs questions yeah
why is Microsoft yeah go ahead return on
investment that's what yeah at some
point that game has to come out you
can't right put more money and at some
point it's like fam you got to come out
now that's it yeah that's business
that's business it is business it can't
be a sink right it can't be a money sync
why is Microsoft and Xbox not getting
any of the blame when they could
actually take a hundred million spend it
on their own franchise rather than just
spending it all on Acquisitions
I would not say that uh I I want ABK I
want it
I do not do not listen into you
um
no
um we have to take these uh take these
chess pieces off the board because oh I
don't want them to stop acquisition I'm
not saying that no no I keep going okay
yeah after this I want to Square Enix I
want to throw so much money on Square
Enix
you sound like Lord Acquisitions let me
tell you something let me tell you
something Jim
as soon as this go through your hair
gonna spin you're gonna be crying for
more stuff you're gonna be crying so
much you just buy it
you know what's funny is like the
PlayStation morale it's like yo that
Deal's about to end oh my God what are
we gonna say so
um yeah we damn I said it certain major
game has
um hit the interwebs
um yeah a lot of a lot of a lot of
things a lot of Auto on the grain scale
and
um yeah I don't want the Rockstar
offense on me a lot of thievery
there's a threats in the streets um we
got to talk about it it broke literally
before we went live
um yeah man so shout out to we want to
shout out our man good friend of the
show Tom Lord Tom Warren yeah shout out
to the Lakers too man because now I'm
reading Tom Warren's article rock star
this is Tom Warren GTA 6 gameplay leaks
online and I'm snitching we don't know
what he's talking about this I'm reading
what the article title name is
you just you're reading off of Twitter
and you don't realize that the mic's
life
is a massive leak early footage man
they're running around here three gig
footage is an understatement there's a
footage the the hacker is known as
teapot tuber hacker claims to be on
behind the unrelated
also claims to be on oh wait he down
with the Uber hack last week oh Mom this
guy is outside so yeah it showed clips
of um female playable character to
include two female protagonists
influenced by Bonnie and Clyde uh
Bloomberg reporter Jason schreier Jason
schreier said
he said that let me put the stuff
um the leak is real Jason schreier threw
sources at Rockstar game the leak video
also currently is posted to Twitter it
doesn't [ __ ] sound like a straight
snitcher
Jason schreier gold
yeah I'm doing this um I remember that
this gift that's me Jason schreier Tom
Warren
um so yeah one video the female
character day Lucia is robbing the
restaurant taking hostages yada yada and
then they show um a playable character
on the Vice City metro train which lines
up with reports the game is an
officialized version of Miami and not
clear how old the footage is but it
appears to be running on a 3060 TI 30 or
80 cards all the clip show NPC and
apparently it's two years away and from
what I understand you know um probably
three at this point yeah the hacker has
requested
that someone from Rockstar intake to
contact them after going viral he person
is very Brazen he's like if you are an
employee of Rockstar a take two go
contact me he said my DMs is lit and you
can email me and I'm we can work out
this deal that's indicative oh I have
more I heard the source code is loose
big two is coming with the dmca don't
come for us because we just read with
Tom Warren and Denison schreier said so
take two time out here
I'm just saying there's an articles
leave us the federalities we don't play
with the Federalists so um yeah so
that's pretty much what Tom said and
this is
let's start with the uh the dip down man
let's start we'll start with KP first
man KP where you at like this is one of
your games isn't it yeah yeah this is
one of my series I didn't want to see it
in this light I was hoping nothing like
this would happen to it but they've been
starving people so long
and and you got some thirsty people that
know to use the PC
I could be wrong this extortion has
nothing to do with that individual
starving this well maybe it does maybe
he wants some money so he don't starve
anymore
yo stop putting them once in the chest
yeah
one one yeah y'all doing me dirty good
yeah
I didn't want to take too much of a
notice on it I've seen it has no no
texture packs or nothing in it but I did
see it I seen she was robbing a Waffle
House or something I ain't gonna lie I
might have watched the whole thing so
I hope
that they get it the game right which I
know well I'm a big rock star fan yeah
no doubt but yeah that's it that's it yo
Stevie Ray dipped down games the news
broke I hit you the DM I was like bro
yeah we gotta change the show putting
those ones in the chat come on with the
one bro that's Tom Warren in them I'm
just reporting what they did
that's what they said I'm just repeating
like that
like the podcast if Colin could
snitching around like a podcast
what you thought man I mean uh you know
I I got a chance to look at it yeah the
KP was saying it it was funny you know
just uh no textures things like that but
it was cool you know I mean
[Laughter]
not one person roll with me that's crazy
I guess the only unfortunate thing about
the whole thing is you know you always
got the people on the social media it's
just kind of dogging in and just
trashing it right you know even though
it's in you know an alpha status you
know they they still like oh my gosh
this doesn't look as good as like San
Andreas or you know this looks terrible
or you know like you know people are
just kind of being a little ridiculous
about it you know it's just it's just
further proof that uh was that
yeah
my man play that shout out to my man
bladex Tony Brown and um
it would just it just shows that um
you know I don't know if the gaming
industry will will ever be able to have
that transparency you know what Gamers
you know a lot of the men a little bit
more you know with uh more of uh just
Bare Bones of the game development side
of things because I mean look what's
happening now I mean they're trashing
this game left and right on social media
uh you know and I guess I have a little
bit of a game uh development background
so I know the difficulties of making a
game I've made a couple games myself
um and it's hard it's hard so you know
just kind of just running their their
name through the mud like that you know
it's a little it's a little
disrespectful yeah then the
repercussions because apparently I saw a
comment from the devs like kind of
pleading with the hacking like you guys
have ruined the whole team like the
hacker put up the response to one of the
devs and it was just like like man you
know like he screenshot it's crazy right
now it's crazy it's crazy like what what
do you get out of it I guess money but
yeah well apparently trying to struggle
him for the for the for the bag
I will say though because I was seeing
some media that was complaining about
the leaks I'm like fam you've leaked all
kinds of stuff oh [ __ ]
it's like some of these media people be
like anything
the title and that somebody's working on
something not like yo here's the source
code he is
most of the time these people got that
they don't do it though but like just
you can't get mad because someone
decided to take the whole thing and not
just give a fry they strong on them yeah
man one of the things that caught my
attention Coggin the articles I mean
this morning was they were going down to
different weapons right yeah you can see
hand guys you can see the machine guns
and then did you see the last part it
says there's even golf balls
[Laughter]
yeah it's crazy man no doubt no doubt
Lord attic wisely told me to take a
certain title's name out of the title
yeah you know you know it sticks Chase
but I saw it pop up in the DMs I was
like yeah
so what's up where we at with these uh
leaky leaks
uh so you know we're gonna refer to the
game as Tom so you know Tom got leaked
this morning
Tom looking rough but Tom is still you
know two years before Tom's born so I
think we need to be kind to Tom because
Tom didn't do nothing to us look
I think what I saw actually gave me a
lot of Hope when it come to
um
just GTA in general like if you listen
to some of the dialogue
it sounds like GTA I know there's a lot
of like fear if they were going to like
be a little bit more you know watered
down than normal GT uh Toms so you know
but it it did if you listen to it it
really felt like GTA like the
conversations you would have I remember
there was a conversation about like
government exactly what I'm standing for
at 13 is talking about time
I actually am a lot more hopeful with
this game now seeing a little bit of the
dialogue and stuff like made me see that
this man hurricane is just throwing
shows oh yeah code after a cold
you know it's funny I ain't gonna lie I
try to snatch that Assassin's Creed wow
and they got it like that's that's
that's that's crazy but it's just like
I think that you know textures aside
everything don't don't look at that look
at the context behind what's going on
yeah you know clearly they they rob in a
waffle house so it's not like the game
is being tooken away from anything like
it that seemed like legit
Tom like
and I think that what we saw is saying
that he was able to sell the GT GTA 5
source code he just sold it yep
so here's the Dig now and as a result
don't they got to redo the whole game oh
this is five oh yeah I don't know any
any I don't know if they're gonna Port
that game anymore yeah yeah
the whole game so now this the rep
repercussions of of a leak like that
that we gonna have to wait for the game
longer if this is five minutes okay
that's it okay I thought it was six oh I
was like oh he's so good and especially
after five that happened you know
Rockstar will never publicly save you
like yo hit me with that PayPal
this is stuff this is stuff he's doing
right now that's gonna get you
assassinated seriously like nah bro you
can't be
he Brazen with it too
that's crazy I'm sorry if you finish
attic I'm sorry yeah it's like I said
man I I think that what I saw that
actually made me excited for GTA I think
that six is looking nice obviously uh
textures and stuff wasn't there but like
the game isn't you know probably just
started mass production so it's just
like what do you expect Tom Henderson
let me put the stop extension Tom
Henderson talking
um he said the hacker has updated the
original post thing that he's looking to
negotiate the deal the hacker has also
said that he has the source code for GTA
5 and 6. then the person pretending to
be a rock star take two employee managed
to speak with the hacker he once again
states that he has the source code and
told him that the IT team can check the
logs for the proof the hacker has now
said he will sell GTA 5 source code and
assets and will not accept any numbers
or off offers under five figures he said
the GTA 6 source code is not for sale at
the moment and he
an anonymous person has apparently
purchased the GTA 5 source code for for
from Bitcoin a worth of a hundred
thousand so that is official the five
has been thanks Tom so yeah Tom thank
you for telling us I'm my man
yeah
[Applause]
I know what's funny like I talked to uh
some people that that do stuff like this
a lot of the time when these stuff is
leaked it was like I wouldn't say being
cheap I don't know if this was the one
doing it because like it's a lot of
places they'll Outsource like PR the
Outsource like uh you know uh testing
the Outsource q a the Outsource a lot of
stuff because they don't want to like
build that that actual that department
in their own studio so that's how you
see this stuff leak because they didn't
do it in-house they did it out and this
is probably how this happened you know
it was probably balanced from you know
especially where we are now with so many
you know remote jobs all it takes is
just one employee that doesn't know what
a hyperlink can do to you and he clicks
the wrong thing and before you nothing
your computer and they and they're using
your computer to go into the other
computer like it's it's real out there
like he said he got it from uh yeah yeah
it's almost a dude lowballed himself
yeah I'll be honest man the situation
just escalated considerably yeah yeah
big time because this has happened
multiple times though this isn't the
first time that this has happened
when you're talking about when you're
talking about GTA 6 source code right if
that gets out there
the decision can be made on Rockstar's
Park to shut the game down yeah and
start again yep
completely completely completely and if
there was ever an inkling of a thought
that maybe we shouldn't invest as
heavily in GTA single player this the
potential for this getting shut down and
then having to start again may cause
them to be like we just keep making
online versions of GTA and no more
single players there's a lot of money
and resources I don't remember I don't
remember
but this isn't this is crazy because if
that gets out there and Rockstar can't
find this person or get it back or I
mean the worst case scenario yeah you
pay the dude to get your source code
back uh DTA we we could be looking at
another decade without GTA a new GTA
honestly so cyberpunk's uh 2077
developers held Ransom after Cyber
attack uh starting to release the uh the
video game source code uh and they want
it back that what's funny
that was the initial thing there was
never a follow-up story I got a break
protocol they got me crazy right some of
those wild disrespectful your baby
father with the ten dollars that's Tom
Warren in them I've just reported what
they said lordcognito after the
detectives gave him a three-piece Papa's
bill with an orange
it reminds me of this of this Tick Tock
I saw where the chick was uh the dude
was his girl was cheating on him and
he's like I'm leaving and he packs up
his stuff and she starts playing anime
he's like that ain't doing it she has
him a a bow of noodles and he's like I
stay for a little bit
that's crazy you know I'm not going to
bother no no developers from Xbox game
Studio I know a couple dudes up here
Cognito can easily be bought for a
three-piece Popeye medal with an orange
thing I ain't telling no about no Studio
couple studios in New York
[Laughter]
this is really it says again if anybody
looking forward to GTA in the next two
years or three years I don't uh uh good
luck
this is how I personally see it going
because it's like I said there's no
return story for the cyberpunk thing to
my knowledge it might have been but I
didn't see they handled it privately
this happens all the time like people
said this is no this happens all the
time multiple times a year where you
know maybe something like that happened
I don't know but all I know is you know
uh these companies like if if they don't
take security seriously and something
like this happens then they're gonna be
like yo hit me with that PayPal link
what's that cash yeah
I don't know has Rockstar ever had a
leak this big or if at all I don't know
but they're most likely if they pay them
they'll be in Bitcoin because that's
usually how stuff like that untraceable
that's crazy you talk about the one
where people were like it was no that
was a glitch that was a glitch that
wasn't that
someone said perspective Canadian bro
stop it bro I need that crash with that
new baby
closed doors regardless if I pay them or
you know or seek him out seek him out
I personally don't think it's gonna like
hiccup too much because it's like I said
I see stuff we see stuff like this on
Twitter all the time yeah I mean they
got to be paying behind closed doors to
keep people's mouth shut like [ __ ] is
disrupting everything because your
thoughts well this is what they get why
that's what they get the hacker was all
Natty on them
slid up right up in their DMS they
thought it was a chick she catfished
them got everything
stop he don't like the weight let's do
it for the employees this is I don't
feel bad for anybody oh come on actually
I don't I don't I do not I do not
speaking you know why no no
you see stuff come out on time stuff
come out on time stuff don't get leaked
how long we've been playing this Grand
Theft Max
we've been playing yo these dudes
actually trying to push it into the Next
Generation too
I don't care you should have got this
game out the door
you could do whatever y'all wanted you
want another Saints Row on your hands
though well this is what happens this is
what happens you made him wait too long
so I get a tweet in the middle of the
night
and he's like look at this
and I see a chick bending down and she
she pulling up on the dude the cash
register the cash allegedly allegedly
this is what my eyes saw in my phone
so anyway so this is what he did see I'm
not snitching
location listen I'm talking about myself
with the first talk to me they gonna
talk to me
what jacket they had on
that boy I don't know said boy all I
know what my visuals saw
okay you describing something I don't
even know what the game was oh now you
don't know what to get right so when I
looked at it I said that you look dope
okay then come to find out is it this
going to do who've been waiting too long
so he had to leak it and he told y'all
hit me with the funds and he lowballed
them too so you know this dude yeah
a hundred thousand I would have milked
the hell out of here
tell me crime don't pay no no prom don't
pay it put the one in the chat if y'all
think snitching continue
put a two in the chat if you think King
doing exactly what king need to do
listen listen
you know he gonna wind up in this
because he sounds stupid first the
hundred thousand that sounds stupid all
right I got the source code I know how
much it's worth it ain't gonna be no
hundred thousand and his life is worth
more than that but he figures a hundred
thousand to get him out of this thing so
he looked at his bills you know what
they probably said King he was probably
like look too many twos in that chat
he's probably looking at he's like a
hundred thousands ain't nothing at them
they'll give that to me just to shut me
up right right he didn't know he all
over Twitter now
he doesn't they don't SWAT him his whole
location everything he gonna never get a
chance to spend that Bitcoin you know
and they paid him in Bitcoin because he
only have a Bitcoin account yeah
the Bitcoin Market just crashed
completely
we worked two cents yo somebody said he
gonna have a fishing accident yo this is
the dumbest dude going and then he tells
you
instead of selling it as a package deal
and getting it out the door
six source code for 16 available for
sale yet
I'll be back for more I'll be
negotiating that yeah
idiot this is the dumb the dumb thing
going but again
they've been holding us hostage I don't
feel sorry for Rockstar they've been
holding us hostage giving us remakes and
keep on dropping expansions and selling
all these Diamond bucks and they've been
juicing y'all for a minute
so all the money they made pay this dude
so he can give you back what he stole
there's nothing all y'all by that in
what was those Casino cards in a week so
y'all paid the hacker in one week I
don't care be honest with you I didn't
really look at it
um does it affect the game I didn't
think the game was coming out in two
years now they may have to redo the
entire game they gonna have to do what
they got to do but I know what they do
this time have better security because I
know I know having Calvin at the gates
I think that's where I am too it's like
look like first off you can never stop
security infrastructure is a hundred
percent but it's just like something
that's this important it's just like I
do feel like they they could have done
something no I don't know man like
hold on a second so you leaving the keys
in the range
one dude messed up apparently the room
the dude that you left security that you
go inside
it's a bad look it's a bad look I really
got much to say on it it's just crazy
this would probably go down as one of
the biggest leaks in in game in history
I feel bad for the desk this is
literally won't work yeah I'm dying to
know what the repercussions is gonna
work if this is it was a phishing email
that's what it was yeah
he's got the same email we got from Gabe
yeah
Nigerian prince
hello what they don't tell you it was it
was
tender yeah
I wouldn't want to be the guy to tell
the boss yo I effed up yeah cause you
the dude that yeah that's it's going to
be crazy he's gone already
yeah I wonder I wonder
if they will go after him legally like
who to do that the dude who leaked it
they all they're going to try it oh yeah
I just hired Calvin I'm gonna meet you
at the Denny's over there to bring you
some money
I personally feel like that's what's
gonna happen they're just gonna pay
these people like that that's what I
feel let's see what happened that's all
I got on that thing I had to talk about
it because it was crazy you want to get
the super chats there's still a combined
topic with the TGs or let me just do the
TGs that's a subtract real quick because
it's not that much
um
we'll go back to hargit to me all this
stuff
[Music]
uh easy one twenty three five dollars
five pounds Super Chat playing Destiny
with the boys for the first time ever
enjoying this so much I never enjoy a
play looter Shooters I have been living
under a rack okay then we got a whole
bunch of codes from Target you need two
dollars Super Chat and a five dollar
Super Chat then another two dollar Super
Chat another two dollar Super Chat then
another two dollar Super Chat you got a
bunch of clothes from Harvey Elgin ring
Global AC Legendary Collection cyberpunk
2077.
um
and then we have a three-month uh Global
Game Pass ultimate code so shout out to
Harvey always looking out for the
community multiple salute funds are
really gaming in the chat I see you
what's going on brother what's good
brother I hope you're doing okay brother
I gotta hit I got my dude
then we got dry drop by Joe five dollars
Super Chat you put a one in the time
what Tom and them said yeah there we go
then we got Tom from Toonami two dollars
Super Chat he just sold uh the the GTI 5
source code and we got that you know it
would be funny if Tom started saying I'm
just reporting with cogs
then we got slow mo backslap five dollar
Super Chat I'm available Rock dot dot
dot make me an offer and I'll make sure
you'll never get hacked again hashtag
networking network engineering mercenary
look at this guy slow be careful man let
them go for GPS and take you down there
we got j15 super chat hello Lords and
dip down games Sun developers on Twitter
are saying that this league may push the
game back almost certainly this really
sucks for Rockstar this sucks for
everybody
then of course I like [ __ ] said yeah
uh there we got y'all baby again two
dollars I got mad love Cog you're my
heart son YouTube
[Laughter]
then we got split different for six
months two dollar people shot Cog you
cheap all it took was Popeye you eating
good though
I just told you about it from Uptown
yeah there we go yeah baby father again
five dollars if it's that I don't feel
bad either Street's been starving one
they got fat off of micro transactions
looking like food in these wow
what's up with them pockets
got some sauce colds in them pockets
then we got Lord Metroid two dollars of
attack car GTA 6 Unsolved Mysteries
episodes
anyway so yeah real quick I I heard that
this what was shacked and shown is two
years old so yeah two years old keep
that in mind
we'll see so look this is the combo
talking so um yeah man looks like uh
Tokyo gaming show we gotta talk about it
man it had the Xbox at the extreme 2022
uh news and updates on 22 games for
majority Jack Japanese developers shout
out to the cops going my opinion on my
mind death Loop they coming for me
the rock stars outside right now no I'm
sorry the cops don't come for the
stitches
[Laughter]
death Loop coming action I'm gonna drop
off some Popeye Chicken
hilarious Yeah man so some highlights
from this man a lot of announcements
about Xbox
um you know um taking rompa fuga
ninokuni obviously uh guilty Street uh
gear shrive and the blue blaze on
crosstag Battle coming to uh Game Pass
iudan won't long I mean this was a lot
of Japanese naraka blade Point got new
content Persona 5 Royale capcom's actual
Primal
um what else we got OverWatch two a new
character
um Dyson Sphere power world kind of like
in the Pokemon kind of thing
um and uh yeah but Melody is still some
other stuff so look just want to know if
anybody got a chance to watch the event
and just thoughts overall Tokyo game
show Lord Stevie Ray dip down any chance
any um chance to look at some of the
Tokyo game show stuff yeah for sure I'm
excited for uh for a few of them uh what
is it EXO Primal oh yeah I'm excited for
that Capcom yep I'll have to just play
that while I wait for my Dino Crisis
that's what I'm really wanting but then
you had the Guilty Gear you know the 2D
Fighters I've always been a fan of those
um and then uh Power world yeah Pokemon
with guns
I said Pokemon but then I see in the
dinosaur you get on the back and he had
the rocket launches and they were right
it's really crazy Steve I was like yo
that truck looked fire
shooting uh like some penguins out of a
rocket launcher yeah I'm about it uh and
then you know that um that Sonic
Frontier
um oh man I'm excited about that I'm I'm
I once not to go back to the Golden Age
of Sonic you know because some of these
the sonics like this was like we was
like a where Sonic a Werehog or
something like that it's a whole other
one I actually really like the uh Sonic
adventures round like those games yeah
oh yeah yeah I'm excited for a frontier
it looks fine I mean Celica can do no
wrong right now they're just hitting
their stride with you know the movies
and all that and yeah
um I'm excited to see what Sega got is
going on
you know they're killing me with the
cops out of here yeah
KP got a chance to watch TGs
yeah I did uh shout out to Xbox they
said they're listening and we can see
they're they're pushing for results
shout out to Sarah Bond Bill Maximus the
Queen the queen and the king
so that they out there making some moves
I see a lot of fighting games coming on
for art systems yeah I see Konami had a
game that's coming over then bro yeah we
got it
108 Stars baby remastered remember that
one and two Street Fighter is looking
pretty good open world creative
character
um got that deaf Loop coming
[Laughter]
was outside
[Laughter]
wait what do y'all think about the game
coming to the PS plus the same day oh I
would tell you like from my understand
um
yeah because they had to have the parody
at the end for for if it comes out on
that service so that's it so but this
was weird though because that service
didn't exist when that deal was made I
don't think what it was is I think Sony
had rights first to anything when it
come to uh marketing or rights to that
game and like right before they lost
those to Microsoft after that time frame
ended that their last hurray was like
We'll go put it on on PlayStation Plus
the the month it comes out I mean so
that's the thing they had to negotiate
that with Microsoft
we don't know we don't know what kind of
deal Bethesda signed with them when they
signed that agreement like they could
have gave them full rights to do
anything they wanted with that IP until
that year was up yeah
I feel like if I don't think there's no
negotiating with Microsoft there I think
that if Microsoft could have prevented
that they would have because it's going
to take a little bit more out of their
wind when it comes to bringing that to
the Xbox platform it's on PlayStation
Plus maybe not a whole lot but I do feel
like you know they would want that whole
they would want that whole month to
themselves that they could yeah like
it's new to us
they remember they was all capping we
got death
you guys made a creature I did review
the game so be sure to go check out that
review yeah yeah he said I think the
exclusivity agreement included first
rights to put the game in their
subscription yeah they get it five
seconds before we put it
we put it too and guess what it's new to
us
so you so they managed to see this is a
funny thing because only Base PS plus
existed at that point right right so
which means they decided okay we're not
going to give it to the base people
we're going to give it to the ones that
are paying the most
uh
that was the joints for you uh but we we
took a slight l too oh
the golden uh
[Music]
that's we could talk about that we'll
follow up with that because that's still
part of the Nintendo Direct technically
oh okay so we will hold on to that one
but yeah hold on but yeah yeah out of
those games yeah of course obviously
came to Game Pass too now so other than
that yeah Xbox did pretty good in in
Japan this year around hopefully it
continues to get better as the install
base gets larger no doubt no doubt Lloyd
attic Tokyo game show your thoughts sir
I liked it I thought it was a you know a
good gesture to get some of these games
that's never been on the platform
especially blaze blue like you know a
lot of people love that franchise got a
lot of uh good getting Persona this year
I think when it comes to me where I
stand with them right now is you're
showing me commitment to the Past
franchises I need to see commitment to
Future franchises and you know I got to
see whether Persona 6 shows up where the
Dragon Quest 12 shows up you know right
now
I got to see more of that and then after
I see that then I will be a lot more
comfortable with them in in Japan but I
I feel like they they did a solid solid
year at TGs no doubt Lord saw your
thoughts on the TGs Showbox
yeah I mean uh I think I think the
overwhelming sort of sentiment is that
they're doing their work over there
right they're doing their work over this
after just cordon and you guys over
there defining Duke and you guys talked
about stuff like they're doing the work
they're doing the work we asked them to
do the work and they're doing the work
um and you know considering the
considering the roadblocks that are
being put by another by competing
companies
talk about later the real snitch in the
room
that the boy King not the point yeah so
you know it's it's spy with my little
eye
so considering all of that they're doing
fantastic work obviously the next step
now is parody right yes day and date I
want them day and Day dead I know I know
Phil and Sarah and the team over there
they're doing that work to try to get
that there because again when you when
you it takes the winds out of sales a
little bit not a little bit a lot when
you talk about you know you can't get
this game for a year two years and and
we're always in the in the dark as to
how long these exclusivity Agreements
are yes so you know but it's really it's
really heartening to see all that King
was saying earlier like the RPG scene on
Xbox through game mask is Bonkers right
now yeah so it really is a big deal to
see like all this Romper to see blaze
blue and guilty gears Drive
come on like strive is huge obviously
strive strive is not going on to Sony's
who knows we could probably see an
announcement that it goes day in day two
into the Sony one but uh Nino Cooney
which is like a PS3 game a remake of a
PS3 game in the car
my knees were given but you know that
Persona five Persona comes I need I need
the Xbox Community to go to be honest
and play the damn game and play the damn
games like you've been asking for this
and they've delivered
in fact so honestly yeah man it's it's
good to see this and it's only going to
continue to get better and grow
yeah what I want from people in this
chat you know I don't care if you even
get smooth it just just load it up to
the title screen screenshot it and post
it on Twitter
like I even might you know talk to the
iron banks if we can give a couple away
the iron bank doesn't have a problem
over so the last thing I'll talk about
is that they went a little bit more in
depth into war long right and they
announced they're talking about the demo
the demos out there right played it
yesterday for about an hour
I'm liking it for it it is that sort of
it is you're not about one love no no
teasing me he teasing me oh okay okay
um it is that sort of mixer besides me
no didn't beat the demo okay beat the
demo but if it is that middle ground of
straight action that you expect from
sort of Team ninja and you kind of like
the the the speed and the movement and
the reaction time of a Ninja Gaiden with
what we've seen from Souls likes and you
know Eldon ring and stuff like that and
and more action-oriented souls like with
the parrying of like a second row and
stuff like that with the RPG elements
you get different stat boosts from you
know different types of weapons
different types of armor you can make a
speed build that's obviously more uh
susceptible to being hit you could make
uh you know heavier builds with heavy
armor and stuff like that the
differences in Magic that you can do a
whole bunch you could summon creatures
you could do different defensive Magics
like
yeah all of it felt like it was more of
a middle ground than a Souls like if
Souls turns you off because it's it's
it's it's super difficult at least in
this early demo it felt like the balance
they reached with that where you have
enemies that are smart they Parry you
they block they sidesteps they're fast
yes it's fast
so the gameplay depends on how how the
build you have so I picked you have an
inventor build a defensive defensive
build a magical poor Bill too which is
kind of weird well they want you to play
multiplayer right they wanted people
yeah yeah yeah it's got multiplayer the
part that I'm curious all the way
through or some anion
the part that the part that I'm more
curious about is like the best way I
could describe to you first off I'm
gonna be real with you guys I I beat the
demo I played like seven hours of this
thing yesterday
the this this is team Ninja's best
did you play
Neo yes
where are you coming from before
any
questions
don't do that to yourself
and how it is how you gonna interrupt me
and say back to myself
exactly right
the whole time yeah interrupts with
circus
how are you gonna interrupt me inside no
that is something that's between me and
Saul
I want to hear more detail I want to
hear more detail because again I played
an hour and I talked about the systems
and stuff like that but you finished the
whole thing yes so I want to hear why
this is their best work this game feels
like like a Sakura like the speed of a
Sakura it feels really solid
um I do think that
this this game like I've always felt
like Neo
was more about like Fast movement
attacks but I feel like this game feels
more precise Precision than anything
else like the Parry stuff is is great
yeah so
it's good man like I haven't really got
too much into like the element stuff
like the the weapons like you got your
your magical attacks you got your just
basic attacks like it it is good it's
it's a solid foundation I'd have to see
the right side that you clearly see The
Inspirations from Neo in here
um people are saying neo3 I wouldn't go
that far I feel like I could see where
you're saying this but like
this game doesn't hold your hand and I'm
not saying Neo did because Neo really
didn't but this game man they they pop
you in there like you go facing you're
facing so because I still understand
like the numbering system in the game I
understand it's like you're fortitude
but I'll be popping up like five minutes
of the gameplay coming across a 25 and
I'm like seven so and you know the the
the boss itself and what I like about
this is all of these what's what I'm
looking for
um games that have invincibility slates
between attacks if you guys know what
I'm talking about like if you Dash
You're Invincible for that duration
certain frames yeah yeah it's got frame
skipping or whatever you like to call it
this game doesn't because when I was
fighting the boss and I was trying to
frame skip between his attacks the boss
is like no you ain't you ain't phasing
through my weapon
so it this game is more about you're
gonna Dodge me like a man and you're
gonna go face through Dodge
like a man that's true anytime I try to
dodge kind of towards him uh yeah I
didn't I didn't feel like I had any
frames of invincibility it was always
best to to Parry or or Dodge away yeah I
didn't sense any frame this I I didn't
sense any of it like I for the most part
I sensed that you know when you fight
these people they want you to actually
Dodge these people they don't want you
to to just you know wait to the right
moment and like phase through them
because a lot of games have that like as
long as you're if you're on point with
the dodging you can dodge under them
when they're attacking and sure you're
not really dodging them it's just the
game is giving you that option where
it's like look like look this dude
clearly hits you but if you if you
corrected it and you did it in that
exact moment we're gonna let her slide
this game's like nah that's the sword is
going up your ass
I liked it I like the you know I'm more
of a fan when it comes to well I'll just
say at the end of the uh the demo
there's like a the boss is human
humanized I like more of those than
fighting giant monsters you know that's
why like secro there's a decent amount
of just fighting humans like human
samurais human demon slaves whatever you
want to call them uh I like that the
first person I fought when it comes to
like a boss thing is a dude with a giant
staff
he was he was rooted with a lot of armor
yeah he was ruthless he and they they
have the like kind of the pairing system
in this game from sakuro uh it was a Neo
but like I feel like it's very more open
in this one like they want to front and
center it's good I think it it
definitely this is the first game I've
seen team ninja make where it's on level
with the from software game so far that
I've seen that last question how to
Graphics it looked good okay I feel like
the character models look crazy yeah
yeah I don't know how like I know like
kid smooth told me that you know black
people hair look okay but I don't know
that because uh but you know as far as I
get it good
I ain't never tried to make a black
person so I don't know if he's
represented you guys fine but you know
because they probably make you fine
because you know you bald yeah yeah yeah
my character came out fine
I don't think you guys will have too
many issues but you know I think this is
good like for the most part I've never
really cared about like the way a
character looks because most of the
games I play you just put a mask over
you don't really see them yeah but the
character models was very detailed like
very deep you can literally like
customize the hair the back of the hair
like the ponytail in the back of the
hair there's like four or five different
customizations
[Music]
your thoughts Xbox Tokyo game show
what's your feelings
uh uh
I gotta take my hat off
that's right buckaroos oh no why are he
here
he's he's gonna show up a little bit
later
he's not here not his secret
damn sure
so he's gonna have to sit down he don't
need to Buck up oh
um
but I I ain't gonna lie man
brought a tear to my eye talk about my
man feel this talk about it doing what
he said he's gonna do yeah he stole my
voice you know damn it I I don't I don't
need I don't need to see more
I hate that boys I hate that like you
get served a good meal
but I need to know what next song is
going to be about no just wasn't in your
second stop it I'm just thought I just
want to push back a little bit and like
I don't want are you talking are are you
talking about the people
are you talking about the people that
just complain in general you talk about
like the people that like me that just
want to see the sequels brought to the
platform I refuse to push back okay
I'm refused to answer that questions on
the grounds that it might incriminate me
oh you know things
come for me
let's go anyway
my man stood on that stage did things he
did things to people's Soul
early in the morning I don't know who's
this person Phil Dominus Maximus are
really expensive first of his name
oh God you said first of his name is
there going to be others in the future
yo is he is
he's conquering and what what y'all what
y'all too busy looking down the road
you're not seeing a Footprints he
leaving in the sand he's conquering oh
you gotta look down you gotta see
exactly what he's reverberating I I
heard some dudes day
oh
Don had uh Kojima before
they have them like this
they have them like this he's outside
you know that was Metal Gear coming
through that was something that was
already done that's on the sidebar slide
that over true that this is you ain't
have it like this ain't sitting next to
him like this the gym in Pocket next to
the guard that's huge
um
see the RPG slate that man digging in
the crates he digging it just seems like
he's going through stuff that he like
and say you know what I heard I heard
this dude didn't play uh Nino Cooney one
let me let me get that let me get this
let me get that
get past looking delicious whoa
Sarah barn and the team out there going
bananas to the queen
every year
at TGs it gets a little bit better
it gets a little bit better okay
continue this is better than last year
yes way better than last year yes
but let's let's talk about
the the game that they showed you they
showed you woo long and y'all was like
oh my God that looks banan I I can't
wait I'm gonna have to buy that first of
all let's come into Game Pass
right now oh
I want more from this dude right now he
giving you he where was Sony at the TGs
show
oh my God here we go because you know I
got to call people out if you ain't
there you you ain't participating right
you did your little state of play did
your stuff on the side because you want
to be separated no
the land you forgot is demands going
there to claim that land
and I told you before I think this is
his mission he wants to be that
Microsoft that Xbox CEO that went there
and left Footprints in the Sand with no
CEO has never done before you you're
gonna remember his name oh you won't
forget it like Troy they're gonna
remember
can I take your knees from him this this
November instead of me talking to the
subjects
that come game awards
it's
y'all y'all seeing stuff that you've
never seen before this is book of X talk
continue you know Peter Moore and them
dudes Miss Walker all that stuff was
fantastic all those games Blue Devil all
those games is great all the stuff was
coming over there's more did you can I
see the new statement when they talked
about the Peter Moore era they talked
about those exclusive games like last
Odyssey and all that and then Sarah Barr
just recently put off shot the video
games Chronicle they said one of the
things they're super excited about is
that they would have over 250 developers
in Japan developing games right now and
that they plan on having original
Japanese titles are currently in the
works for Xbox they had to Phil
reiterated when they're talking about
those demand for original Japanese games
we are working on creating such titles
it's not much too much to hope for we
just met with Kojima from Kojima
Productions and many other game creators
to talk about bringing unique titles to
the Xbox we understand that many game
fans want that we also are aware of the
common desire for gings from Japan we
are working on creating such titles so
please look forward to it that's what
I'm saying and he said his relationships
with Japan
it's good
he's there boots on the ground he ain't
taking it for granted street team
he's outside knocking on doors he's
shaking hands and kissing babies ain't
no feel over there it's a lot of serious
asses being sold they said that's the
gateway drug into the house little man
wouldn't rampant
Game Pass is tearing it up pgs show was
Microsoft show God bless
look kid really follow up with such a
tremendous word from the book of X right
there
um I'll just add up because I'm with
King on this one I listen we got it we
gotta stop playing give it up what
they're doing is it's one thing to talk
about it it's another thing for the
action to actually commit and it's been
a slow progression year after year after
year I'm gonna tell y'all right now that
was one of the best shows they put on
not only to the attention to detail
because let's be honest Xbox is not the
greatest reputation with their showcases
this was a love and respect of Japanese
culture the way it was handled the
format was great they addressed a lot of
these now people could say because those
games are old and I didn't listen to
what I'm telling you in order to get the
respect you have to get those holes and
those franchises that were missed so
that now you can build upon when the new
release comes out you have the catalog
same thing with Persona Nino coding all
these things that myth guilty get I've
been born there we had for fight against
me we see fruits of that labor right now
at the Yakuza franchise yeah exactly no
we weren't getting none of those but now
all of them have been announced all of
them announced Isha nothing missed
except we're going to talk about that
one particular company yeah we'll get to
them later but that money don't talk
about that one joint but the thing for
me
fighting games what the hell is going on
yes you know what I'm saying like KP
mentioned the Guilty Gear the ark system
the attack it they didn't miss the
street fighter they didn't miss listen
they're not missing so again look at the
you gotta build the bricks Rome is not
built in a day they are putting in the
work then on the NBC nobody talk about
my naraka blade Point that's still
exclusive and y'all ain't playing like I
I see like y'all not playing so
everybody that said they need to do they
are fruits of Labor being laid before
you right there they're putting in the
work so that's what I want to see just
want to see that commitment I think it
was an important showing that they had
you know I'm willing I listen I'm
willing to bet I think Persona 6A Miss I
think for so I'm not saying gonna be
guaranteed
um game pass but I know I think it's
going to be on days
I'll take it these I'll take anybody I
think I think it is depending on how
five it depends on
I don't think it has anything to do with
the cells of five I think it has to do
with if Sony already locked that out a
long time ago
day and date let's go Game Pass no no no
Game Pass I'm just saying day and date
it will not miss the platform that's
what I'm going with it yeah I think
that's that and then um look we talked
about the Yakuza series we talk about
naraka shout out to um launch Stevie Ray
I'm with you EXO Primal look
phenomenal.com that looks great and look
they suggested they're not stopping
they're not stopping it it's good to see
because look I got to keep it real quick
and y'all know I'll be on my Peter more
but Phil is doing something that no Xbox
CEOs does probably period period like
you're over there you're out you know
what the significance of that then you
see the Kojima joint he's out that like
they're not playing Sarah over there so
I didn't that's insane don't look it is
what it is oh blade X what's up man you
won't put I don't see nothing what's
going on
you know what I'm saying but yeah like I
said remember I remember these comments
when it happens just don't disappear
like that other kid what's his name he
never showed up again
I want the Super Chat when you lose
I want that too so we we could do the
bending music yeah
cause I'll be like yo I've been in there
I lost and that's it that's it you move
on Just Be A Man About It so if you want
to do that let me know hit me up and it
is right in November yeah
it is what it is
no doubt so look that's what I wanted to
say and I just want to get on their
flowers on that let's get these super
chats all right cool we got
we got fawns and rally gaming we have
five dollars to protect love you guys
thank you for bringing joy to this
community every week big shout out to
King for hitting me up recently it meant
so much without Fox I love you my dude
we have Dano remember for 28 months Lord
bronze the hacker said show me your
bills
it doesn't put the crust in the chat for
the newest member of the realm wavy
kosher no baby that's what's up then we
got Phillip Phillip one was he one and
the Beast two dollar Super Chat I
haven't read it wrong both times
um shout out to you so thank you and
that's it we're caught up all right no
doubt no doubt let's move this on again
another little combo joint
um so you want to set up how you want to
do that you want to accept the Nintendo
so actually solve could set up the
detective direct and then we can go
right into it with the um octo situation
yeah all right yeah so we had a Nintendo
Direct on Tuesday the first like you
know kind of large scale Direct in a
while they've had Direct Minis and then
and like Indie showcases and stuff like
that
um and there was a lot to say you know
maybe not everything was for everybody
but there was a lot to say in almost 45
minutes of uh of a direct right so
obviously the big news we have the title
for the sequel to breath of the wild the
good tears of the kingdom and we have a
release date uh which is uh May
something it's May something anyway
middle late May uh release date for
Zelda tears of the Kingdom I firmly
believe that before then or around them
we'll have new Switch Hardware whatever
that is it'll be a switch it will be
switch part and we still live it all
with this dream of a new switch it to
happen it's gonna happen
um so we have that we got Fire Emblem
and Gage we got a bunch of stuff uh we
got a bunch of farming simulators
um but we got some cool games uh some
games do not seem to be running super
well on the switch
two [ __ ] shout out to to sifu
um
um we have a bunch of new N64 games
coming to the the platform uh the
biggest of which is Goldeneye uh
obviously rare and and Microsoft getting
together to make this happen GoldenEye
coming back to the N64 uh Nintendo
online service and it will have online
multiplayer
in a way that the Xbox version won't
have but
um I I my belief is that the Xbox
version is a truly upgraded sort of
version at least in terms of frame rate
and stuff like that whereas the the
GoldenEye I feel it's just it's it's
just that game in the backwards
compatible rapper that they have for N64
and most games in that servers if not
all have uh online play so it just kind
of feels like you know what we did used
to do with excellent excellent Kai and
stuff like that tunneling software to
sort of get multiplayer to work on like
Halo 1 and stuff like that it kind of
feels like that's what's happening here
but again it's something that the Xbox
version doesn't have
uh beyond that we got a lot of updates
for a lot of games we got Pikmin 4
finally announced uh to be coming out
soon although it was announced you know
whatever eight years ago
uh a bunch of uh Resident Evil games
coming to streaming and stuff like that
it was a lot there was a lot to talk
about
um overall wasn't really for me in terms
of the stuff they were talking about I
was more excited for for new stuff and
we we got a lot of new stuff but just
stuff that wasn't really peaking my
interests on the switch per se
um but again a lot of stuff to talk
about if you if you're a big Nintendo
fan and speaking of stuff to talk about
at that Nintendo cover there's a
specific game that uh was announced
there was
octopath traveled too oh that one did I
did I conveniently left out of what I
was saying
ironically is that on Playstation
currently and uh we got it on Game Pass
and it's looking like the sequel was uh
skipping only one platform uh you know
and what's funny is that that's Xbox so
you know you could think you could take
the Stitch the stitching Jim Ryan for
that one uh so yeah that that that's
what we talked about that's where the
smoke is man the lack of octopath two on
the Xbox platform this is what makes me
worry about that Persona 6. this type of
foolishness like I just don't understand
right I don't understand it it just does
not make any sense and this is where
sometimes I just feel like it's
particularly with Square Enix that that
the closeness of that relationship with
PlayStation is like certain
conversations just happen in a way that
at this point Microsoft still can't even
hope to have right there's a lot of
stuff in pocket and it just feels like
this is one of those things like nah
they don't get that you know because it
feels really Petty too like if there's
anybody who's gonna lock this down we'll
probably should be Nintendo right not
Nintendo don't care yeah that's the
thing they don't right it just it just I
don't know it's just this so this is
what makes me worry about Persona things
like this happening the thing that I'm
willing to say is
I don't think you have as much to worry
about Persona 6. I do think the only
real thing you have to worry about
Persona 6 is whether or not
Sony lockdown Persona 6 right after five
because people think Royale was five no
there was before Royal was Persona five
so they had that two years I think was
between five and Royal to secure that so
there's a good chance I would probably
about 50 50 that Persona 6 already has
some kind of uh exclusivity on
Playstation but we don't know that until
we actually see marketing for it but
it's just like this makes me start to
feel like the only reason
that I can see score Enix doing this is
if they've already verbally agreed to be
bought by Sony because it it's not like
it was skipping
switch
or I don't know if it's coming out on PC
or Playstation like it's only skipping
Xbox it's so it's just like to me the
only way that makes sense because we got
to how is it we get the Pre-Sequel and
Sony doesn't have the the Pre-Sequel
known as octopi traveler one have the
first but we don't even get the sequel
but Sony gets the sequel so to me it
kind of makes me think that it's like
look we have verbally agreed to be
bought by uh Playstation they probably
don't have no contracts so they think
it's more and I personally feel like
this this is like that
good good gesture thing because like I
just I can't think of a reason why I
would skip Xbox I just I just can't you
know besides like little things like the
mar uh the Mega Man uh collection not
hitting Xbox for the most part A lot of
these sequels have you know the Sega
games some bam Namco games but this
particular one is just like it would be
different if we never got the original
octopod traveler but clearly there was
enough of a relationship to get it on
Game Pass so there's two different
there's two different roads all right
there's the left Road
where Sony has verbally agreed to buy
this call to this game and they're like
we don't want nothing on Xbox which
we've seen consistency with that besides
one game which is Final Fantasy
um uh reunion which I I don't know what
that's about but then there's the right
where some of these Studios see that
they can hold their games for Rants and
we get a Game Pass back later after
launch uh so I don't know which one it
is but I think it's one of those two
roads fair enough Lloyd Stevie Ray the
lieutenant director and the octopath
situation
I'm kind of would solve on it I mean it
was a cool direct nothing really for me
though I I mean my relationship with
Nintendo has kind of died down over the
years uh their games are just a little
too big for me you know like I just
don't have time for legend of zeldas the
Mario galaxies or I'm sorry Odyssey and
all that uh I wish I would you could see
like a Bayonetta like on a real console
took so long like imagine Bayonetta on a
Playstation or Xbox it's like oh I'm not
gonna lie that triangle strategy game
that's coming to PC like you know that's
a good game and even that turn-based
game was struggling on the switch at
some point so it's just like part of
me's like yo you know they got that for
the right price I might Replay that at
the way it was meant to be played like
real console
my bad
[Laughter]
thing which sticks happening uh you know
it doesn't really hit home for me again
no one of those games I just didn't play
too much but I can see you know the the
frustration or the you know maybe a
little bit of the anger behind you know
getting one but not two things like that
but yeah I know Sony's been doing it for
Generations now right and Xbox blocks
have been saving up all these rainy days
of losing this game losing that third
party game and then when the activation
act the Activision uh Bill closes you
know then you know we'll get we'll get
we'll get that day so yeah yeah
that's what I'd be thinking man they'd
be looking at that Activision jail be
like Microsoft has been on a leash for
the past year they're looking at that
deal closing like
I'm scared what happens when that bank
account unlocks again
even with a deal clothing they're going
to be very aggressive
afterwards
the light in his eyes see are you flame
[ __ ]
how could you see I could just see Phil
Spencer like looking at like the uh you
know the Jim Ryan comments and it's like
oh oh you you think we being unfair
just wait Jimmy
the Lord KP Nintendo Direct and the
octopath two situation what are your
thoughts sir
uh Nintendo Direct I checked out they
had some cool stuff most of it now for
me I don't even play the switch anymore
myself I do have my son playing on one
okay okay I love for Nintendo I dip down
I guess not not getting the Nintendo
base but I I do I do follow I follow the
games that they release
you know but they decided to talk about
something I I might miss it
I heard about them
that's it
yes I can tell you the J the I the m the
m
always Jimmy hold up
I think he I think they had something to
do with that because oh I think they got
their hands in square and they showing
them
first
yeah they showing them the
bills now we'll take that they got the
last one
yeah they've been very selective and not
trying to give Xbox like the most
popular square games
you see what I mean nitpicking with them
oh they can get this one right they
can't have that one you know in this one
yeah I think squares
making some moves for Sony just to buy a
couple of their Studios because I think
they're gonna be selling studios off so
Nintendo they kind of already have to
right Square yeah yeah so I think it's
gonna be a lot more of that because
they're reporting all these record loss
yes
you know be funny if they uh
they're they're talking to Sony about a
potential buyout they just gave them a
list of stuff that yeah the reason they
didn't want them for like oh they don't
like our Western Division so we could
sell that oh like we gave gains to Xbox
we can fix that yeah yeah no I feel it
yeah yeah that's it what's up did you go
I forgot I'm sorry yeah yeah Kings your
thoughts on octopath and the Nintendo
director I know you watched that
Nintendo yeah
um
what the hell is that Zelda game oh yeah
tears of the Kingdom that's the sequel
to breath of the wild okay so that's the
breath of the wild because I was like I
thought it was supposed to say breath of
the wild too yeah and I was sitting
there like wait a second did they just
them did they just bamboos with me and
say we're gonna throw this out then
we're gonna give you the breath of the
wild too on the next time okay good all
right so I walked away from that show uh
really enlightened with uh some of the
stuff that they did show I liked a lot
of stuff
um again my son plays uh his switch uh
breath of the wild is what I will play
definitely you know I play in Doc mode I
do not play in portable I don't like
cataracts
octopath traveler too
um Sony didn't get octopath traveler one
correct so they get to
and and I believe they're gonna do this
thing they're gonna do a flip-flop
uh Game Pass is gonna get octopath
traveler too
and uh Playstation Plus uh store
whatever the hell that is is gonna get
uh octopath traveler one
and they're gonna Rectify that I don't
think isn't anything nefarious around
going in there it squares notorious at
Bad Business they've been having record
losses and stuff like that when he
started messing with Jimmy every time
they started messing with Jimmy listen
to what Jimmy talking about they've been
looping bread right because smart
business tells you to put it where
everybody's at nobody's listening to the
PlayStation service I don't hear nobody
nobody's running in the streets talk
about yo you heard they just dropped
yesterday no I don't see nobody posting
anything for all you PlayStation dude I
don't see it so I don't I don't uh
subscribe into that as far as
PlayStation is holding them back I think
they're doing it to themselves I agree
you know and if that bag is there humble
yourself walk or walk across the street
man go to the green light the green
light on all night long just walk up in
there and be like yo we would like to
put our games on your services I know
we've been acting up get that Final
Fantasy out the door but when you're
doing nefarious stuff with that dude the
background you can't show your face I
get it
listen all sins are forgiven all you got
to do is confess on the book put your
hand on the box
all sins are
forgiveness and then then we go we take
you from here don't worry about it and
they ain't got more money than Xbox so
stop acting like you rolling with the
big dog you're rolling with the poodles
they have a long-standing relationship
like Sam said they've got a lot I don't
care about that long-sanding pig when he
gonna wipe you
I mean again they say yo man you need
you know you're a little a little thick
around the waist yeah
they got rid of it they got rid of the
crystal D they got it you know what a
real man do or not let him buy the big
girl just like that you love the whole
package
went over went over to ABK and said I
take all of that girl where it was
Square was they first like let's be real
and KP we can talk I'm falling in love
with the first he break your heart yes
they they did the most money over there
I mean I should say they did the most
but when that Final Fantasy uh seven
drop on PlayStation the relationship was
born like you don't say like you know
what they got to do they betrayed the
technical thing what they got to do they
got to listen to old boy
two alpha males walk in the room
and there's a girl in there they wooing
one alpha male say he got stuff I can't
compete with
you gonna still walk with that dude that
can't compete with that dude are you
gonna leave with that alphability
they was there from day one nah forget
the past it's over it's over
listen they gave they gave that girl
shelter with Nintendo situation wasn't
ain't nowhere to go they get that Final
Fantasy and then the rest was history
listen I always gonna be deep ties with
them oh listen
beware
when this deal closed
beware
my man told you he wants you
and he likes you gonna get you I don't
care what you say
um
and you know why because these other
dudes been playing around they've been
they don't drop Crystal D long time ago
pause they don't drop all these other
things then did all this stuff for you
they don't jump they don't gave you
Final Fantasy for how long they don't
did all of this stuff Jimmy when are you
gonna marry me Jimmy doing everything
else Mary and everybody else but you why
because he got you in Pocket oh okay how
long are you gonna be a fool for Jimmy
step overhead to a man that's really
gonna put a ring on that see that you
put a nice ring on there and you're
gonna love you for real
okay I see what you're doing I see what
you do it look man it's a funny one you
know um this listen I still believe
square or the Ellis mercenaries in
gaming I think to be honest yes there is
loyalty to sodium
I think just by the way they move like
they don't even keep track of all the
bags they take like like how you go
let's just look at octopath objectively
how the first game comes out on Nintendo
switch
then goes to PC the next year then the
Xbox gets the Game Pass back a
completely misses PlayStation so if the
logic is you're going to sell the most
on Playstation they don't buy they don't
even listen to their own logic
you literally missed out on the
quote-unquote biggest place octopath can
eat at you didn't take that back right
The Game Pass join this dance step now
the sequel comes out it's on PC
PlayStation everybody else except Xbox
right so you just split up the
continuity of a hot new franchise for no
reason so PlayStation guys can't play
octo one
XBox guys get the series can't play octo
2 what are you doing right just for the
continuity it's stupid so what it shows
me is you're willing to take the bag no
matter what you're willing you're
willing to sit whoever's the biggest bag
was going and this is my theory my
theory is whoever Birkin bag is who's
going to pay for this month's rent
because like KP said the financials came
out oh you know we were kind of hurting
and we gotta we don't even know if we
can keep these Studios then you sold
Crystal D embracer came in drop the bet
you got rid of all that quick oh Google
take that take that off us we yeah they
made Avengers they we lost the money we
thought that was gonna be too big you
quick to take bags quick so to me
this either is one of two things like
addict said it's either one they sat
there on two and was like you know what
okay we can get the money for Nintendo
we get all these bad okay cool and then
with Xbox you know what that game pass
back was nice
here's the game new game pass price for
if you want to and maybe Xbox is like
not fam not like this like we gave you a
bag for the first trip because it makes
no sense to skip Xbox
you got the first one there so clearly
you act in my opinion you're asking
price for the game pass bag is a bit
much and people say hey that's you know
they deserve the right because maybe
they didn't feel the physical sales or
whatever fine all I'm saying is they are
inconsistent with their own logic that
means you are chasing the bag at first
priority here's the same thing Final
Fantasy 7 remake okay cool gonna give it
over there why the hell is Xbox getting
crisis cool if they can't even play the
remix
make it make sense square like that's
all I'm saying that's what you're just
all over the place out rise okay we're
gonna take the Game Pass back here right
they make no they got different
divisions okay so clearly nobody's
talking to each other it's just like yo
it is to check this week this was giving
us that
I don't know what's going on this is
extremely weird to me PlayStation fans
lose out Xbox fans lose out and at the
end of the day it's like I said it's
attic says one of two things
it's either times are hard on the
Boulevard and you won't take whatever
check you're gonna get to get through
or what soft said or whatever or attic
also said you make it yourself sexy for
acquisition you need someone to pay the
rent consistently you need a ring on
your feet because clearly you are not
doing well you can't keep track of what
you are giving exclusives to
you don't even know what's going on
you think they looked at the
presentation like wait a minute
wait how is PC get it how PC getting it
that's Microsoft anyways it's
mind-boggling to me they said oh we
thought PC with Microsoft
I think it's physical it's just crazy
I've just gotten to the point with this
whole PlayStation and Square Enix thing
that's like Microsoft they literally
low-key extorting you and hold holding
their games
because you can't tell me that Xbox
ain't trying
there's no way on this Earth you gonna
tell me that Xbox don't want octopath
traveler just tell them no like look
like as much as I would like these
particular because this isn't a I got to
the point this isn't a Japanese problem
this is a Square Enix
yeah and it's just like
I'm at this point where I'm like if I
was filled I'm looking over there and I
see them deliberately leaving stuff out
they're not trying to have conversations
they're not returning our conversations
I don't know if they're not returning
but yeah
and I'm just sitting here and I'm like
all right we're not we're not messing
with you at all like if you want to be
bought by PlayStation
go to PlayStation let them fund
everything and I think I honestly think
I get I have no insights
I honestly think she got gassed off of
the The Game Pass back the first time
yeah and her number her number went up
and she thought they gonna get after me
no problems like Vietnam no they did it
with uh they did a bunch of games like
they did with all the Final Fantasy
games at one point they did it with um
octopi traveler they did it with uh
what's funny is is I don't think that I
don't think have we seen anything
recently like Square Enix games going to
Game Pass since October traveler I can't
remember but you know you know what I
know they they
don't talk about development time either
because you make it into a switch and
you're making it on PC don't talk about
you ain't got enough time like bro you
making it on everything
you literally are doing this so it's
just funny like I just look at square
but I will say I gotta give as much as
I'm I'm going in on Square
I gotta give them this
King excuse my language that box has got
to be hot because everybody want them
games everybody when they drop when they
drop something I it's something about
these Square Enix games I'm not gonna
front There's Something About Mary
something about marriage
everybody go crazy everybody want them
so I got to give them that they do move
the needle it's just funny how she is
just again they don't have time to make
it because they're making too many
farming simulators that's all
if they cancel two of those farming
simulators there you go
they what it is they they know that when
it comes to jrpgs they're the they're
one of the hottest chicks around so it's
like look like you know if you if you if
you want to participate in these
activities you're gonna pay that money
and I think my it seems like Microsoft
you got the points like no like you got
I mean you got friends they might not be
as cute as you but we can mingle with
them too I think it's coming to Game
Pass I want you a call with octo one see
the thing is though I if I have to pick
between them being ransomed and they and
they're not respecting the Xbox audience
enough to give us these games get day
one I only want the thing on the
platform at this point because it's just
like you don't you don't no no no like
Square Enix don't respect the Xbox
audience enough to let them have those
games day one then they needs to be some
tough love like because
we're just gonna keep letting them do
this though do whatever she wants go
ahead God bless you yeah
when I got room in my schedule I'll
slide you in my game I mean I would say
if if the issue is they look at the Xbox
and like nah whatever no that's one
thing right then yeah okay be angry at
them be whatever but if it's a I can't
get mad at them for a bag because they I
mean that's what they do that's business
that's business whatever the price is
this week
um
what if we looking at it wrong
have traveler doesn't fit that month
that they have allotted for Day One
releases inside game pass it could be
that we got some crazy games but see but
at that point you're putting it on
Microsoft
I'm just saying this I'm just saying it
probably they asked for something the
price was a little bit weird and they
was like well in this month we have this
Premiere game that we have to launch
inside Game Pass so we can miss uh uh a
couple of months on that and then we can
probably fix you in sometime in January
can't just release it
and then a couple months later it comes
on Game Pass so here's my thing that's
all cute and all but it's never a couple
months it's years yeah and I'm not
trying to sit here a wait couple years
for octopi travel too and then and then
guess what whatever they work on next
same thing we're gonna have to wait a
couple years at that point it's like no
if you ain't gonna respect us enough to
give us that stuff on day one keep your
dogs
if they on Sony if Sony purchases them
um
yeah
but but at that point that I'm okay with
it because Sony actually went out and
they did that but it's just like we're
talking about score in it but they don't
like the fact that she got the right to
choose
oh
my God
just don't want to go over there today
God bless you God bless you listen she's
the bills are high this buff and she
went a Lambo don't worry don't run a
roll back around
yeah we know how I go we know how I go
you know how it is this is gonna be
funny we'll see how it is
part of the topic state of play bang oh
yeah stay the plate stay to play again I
wasn't expecting this camera
oh no here we go here we go tonight out
of 10 but I think I'm about to head out
guys
I'm about to pass out I haven't ate
nothing all day
we coming out five like yeah this is the
final part of this you know how we do
it's a really quickly state of play
happened uh last week as well same day
as the uh Nintendo Direct a little bit
late in the afternoon
um and yeah we got some bangers I yeah I
honestly wasn't expecting much and we
got a whole bunch uh we started off with
Tekken eight looking real thank you
I thought it wasn't really yeah but then
when I saw it I was like that looks real
that looks like it can be done
so yeah Tekken 8 looking super
impressive I really want to see what
they what they do with the franchise
it's been a long time since second uh
seven
um especially overall like Tekken 7 was
in the arcades for a minute before it
came home so we're looking at like seven
years since Tekken something like that
it's kind of crazy so to see it come
back um and looking like this is
fantastic we got a whole bunch of
announcements uh related to psvr2 yeah I
kind of thought we would get right maybe
a really uh maybe that price point but
maybe release date kind of maybe
pre-order starting
point what's up Buck what's going on
Buck you call me Wild Buck please thank
you did I say my name say it right said
correct
I have to say about about the the state
of play
[Laughter]
let me tell you
uh y'all like that PlayStation VR too
nice
y'all thought chair was bringing your
catalog along
[Laughter]
the remasters and a lot of remakes
coming your way
get those bucks in order uh you replied
that's why there's no backward
compatibility sir so you can monetize
future releases not one lick of it
you will not ever I'm done load up that
PlayStation 4 game in that PlayStation 5
we believe in Generations over here
this is the generation we believe in you
was waiting to hit you oh
man I gotta say this
y'all see that controller yeah
go buy it buy it with the game turn that
purchase into a 400 purchase
state of play was the best state of play
that we had 10 out of 10.
that's fire it was fire it was fantastic
ain't no denying
oh man all I got to say is
we're gonna push uh God of War to
January
yeah
I just want to let Lord
knows just just slide your knees over
the king
it's right we got a nice little chopping
process put your legs on the board
you can slide right over chop them right
off oh nice and dandy it's okay Wild
Buck uh I will still take his knees just
fine I don't need your opinion
I do like everything that was there man
yeah it was a fantastic shoe we
appreciate it we appreciate your
feedback while bucket especially the
psvr situation in your decision process
that's right they're gonna pay more like
like that like that guy ever born says
charging more I like that guy I like
that thank you
thank you for your consumer friendly
policies thank you very much WoW [ __ ] oh
yeah dip down games uh Lord KFC let's
start with you first um did you watch
the uh state of play and what was your
thoughts on it
oh yeah while Buck neither need a theme
song
[Laughter]
you mean like uh what What's that show
with the with the the orange car Dukes
yes just the good
The Good the state of play state of play
was fire it came on into a fire like
what is this
I mean we couldn't distinguish if it was
a CGI or gameplay
yeah that came off impressive yes um
that Stellar blade
hell yeah hell yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah fine so that was they didn't
get banned later they got that what yeah
King some dude named Wild Buck just
hijacked your camera a minute ago oh
that's my cousin
you work at Sony
[Music]
so the other team ninja game that Sony
uh is fronting the money for was that uh
the Ronin yes yeah
yeah that looks pretty fire too as well
got to see more on that one before I'm
100 I don't know I'm 100 once they open
those wings up I was like yeah I don't
know what this jumped off
how vicious they was yeah yeah and then
they put they put the icing on top of
the cake of the show they put the gow on
the g-o-d
yeah I kind of didn't want to see any of
that but that's why do you like did you
like it did you like all that gameplay
they showed all that finished gameplay
that was an excellent vertical slice I
mean Stony with their movie studios the
way they know how to cut trailers yeah
shows off in their games yes perfect
stuff no doubt yeah so uh me I I rate it
I give it about a a
let's say about an eight and a half yeah
I think was yeah
was the uh the lady talking about the
Stars PlayStation day yeah I don't know
what that's about man that could have
been a tweet or a YouTube video yeah
I mean one would say that you got to
reward them for even buy the PlayStation
these days
as soon as they raise the price you can
find them all over the place
[Laughter]
no doubt eight out of five okay that's a
strong score no doubt all the other
people who have watched it what the
comments are
I mean I guess I'll say something you
know
I I liked it I thought it was a solid
show
um I I gave it a nine out of ten
um I do feel like some of those content
I need to see a little bit more on some
of those like Ronin
um but you know I really liked what I
saw a God of War because I felt like it
showed us that you know this game Gonna
Come Out Swinging now I don't know if
it's gonna swing too much but you know
one thing I do know is it's swinging out
this year
I'm excited because like the next six
months of gaming is just yeah it's
correct
ridiculous like I don't even know how
I'm gonna do it like I'm I'm I might get
broken up with over this [ __ ] like six
months
because like when we were February I
remember because I reviewed two games of
February my girl's like man you've been
playing a lot of games here like I'm
like babe this rarely happens well about
that about that yeah get ready get ready
for these next couple bucks yeah no
doubt Lord solve your thoughts on this
day to play everybody
yeah I mean I like I said man like
everything shout out to demio showing
his face
so proud yeah I I they probably gave
them a pretty good bag but I'm just like
man you don't want to be even better
like on all the platforms cross-play
yeah I'm hoping that happens on the
because I feel like in order for that
game to really take off it needs to be
on everything and the thing is the fact
that they're getting the PS VR2 version
and a console version yeah
I told people that's gonna move and then
to move that VR and it has some games
for it like they they got they're
starting off right man yeah they
definitely are but for me the rise of
the Ronan was the one that really stood
out because it was like yeah it just
felt like it was doing you know
Fantastical stuff but still somewhat
grounded obviously the the the hang
glider thing is it's more fantastic but
um just to see that it was a lot of
Samurai stuff obviously the all the the
expansion to the Yakuza franchise with
the like a dragon well everything's
gonna be called like a dragon you know
moving forward ishin is a game that
never got localized localized now and
mind you they said they're not dubbing
it so it'll still all be in Japanese but
um but to see it Stateside just goes to
show where you know the Yakuza is really
blown up over here and to see that come
over
yes sir you read the um reasons why um
Yakuza like a dragon was inspired to
bring it over to the states okay please
be Enlighten us they saw the sales and
the domination franchise
the success that they think you know
what the American public likes those
Samurai
the the ninja part is being you're being
generous
well the story is a man transitioning
here's a budget ninja
plus Samurai the budget ninja
white because I know you guys like that
classic you know subbed stuff but I'm
not like when it comes to games I like I
like English voice acting I like trying
to read nothing like so like I didn't
know that until just now I'll probably
skip that game boy because I ain't
trying to read like
I ain't trying to do none of that
nonsense
listen to me that one is the one that
stood out the most because again it felt
the most grounded uh I want to see more
like you know how
and stuff like that so um again because
not since not since Bushido Blade
they've really got into that you know
the the the sort of because again ghost
did it very well but ghosts arcade to
fight a little bit right it gave you
like it gave you the moments and it gave
you the Ambiance but when you're
fighting it you know they they sped it
up it's not like what what you'd expect
from Samurai necessarily they sped it up
a little bit I really like the way the
samurai games yeah so they that's this
Ronin game has really stood out to me uh
it's exciting I'm the one uh what it's
called Stellar or whatever it's I it's
just too much of that that's the one
that to me is like it's two Japanese and
it's like it's over the top you know the
booby physics and stuff like that
you know I'm not that age anymore yeah
I'm not that age anymore so it doesn't
really appeal to me like that like that
but um
I just overall is not what I expected
from the state of play I I did not
expect all of this I expected the God of
War stuff which I did not want to see
but once I saw it I couldn't turn away I
was like oh damn it this is I'll just do
it
um but that's it I'm not seeing anything
else I got a war
yeah man's quick I mean pretty much
y'all said all my points I thought this
show was phenomenal I thought they
really killed that's probably one of
their best I haven't really been a big
fan of state of plays to be honest
unless it's like a single game showcase
about a big title about to be released
this was their best rate I mean also it
was all for me they were like Carl
everything you want here we go they jump
off the rip Tekken eight off the rip
ground running to the point the game
looks so phenomenal and Unreal Engine
five with the cuts I was like that's not
real I was like that's a CGI until
harada them had to come out it was like
no this is what it is it's going to
continue the machine storyline I know
that storyline from Tekken one I've been
through every techie game every check
the stats I've done it or a hundred
percent of the damn games all the time
and it's gonna now be the gym because of
a kazoo your machine we've been waiting
for we know what happened with the
hayachi if y'all didn't play Tekken
seven and I want to know what they do
that I would love
um a June callback I feel Judy is
important to the story and we need
Clarity after Tekken 3 with the whole
ogre situation because some people came
back from ogre some people survived some
people didn't you know that kind of
thing so um I'm surprised we got eight
though y'all so because
the Cadence usually is Tekken Tag yeah
then hey you know I thought it'd be like
seven Tekken Tag three then eight they
jumping right into it so I want to see
that they also got to explain because
technically Akuma was Canon
in Tekken seven and if y'all play Tekken
7 we're gonna beat it something happened
at the end there's a matchup and I need
to know what happened because clearly
kazulia is running around so I need to
know about that
um it's great I think they could do some
cool things it's gonna be a little
technical Tech I want to know what they
do post mashima I mean um with hayachi
with the law situation he's a he's a a
direct descendant yeah so he's like a
love child at hayachi had other side and
he's a tech enforcement so I want to
know if his joint the only thing I need
for them is up your neck cold please
please yes roll back roll back everybody
please please upload your net code
second I need Tekken the reason why I
fell in love with Namco is it was the
only fighting game that when you played
every character you had an ending yeah
you had a narrative for that character
seven put the rage system all these fly
featured the game of seven is amazing
the problem I have with it is if you're
not the mashima and maybe 4 four
characters out of this 30 you don't get
no ending like no we're not doing that
Namco go back to what made you great
because you got Mortal Kombat out here
giving you full cinematic stories with
everything everybody everybody in the
joint please put in the time to do what
y'all do I think they blew the budget
honestly with Akuma I think they're cool
things just blew the budget there's like
yo we gotta cool man we got to focus
around I get it go back to your roots
other than that boom I'm ready to go
demio resolution game I'm so proud of
y'all so proud of you obviously you know
I'm Team Quest but I am so proud of them
to see this game shine it's my little
joint you know what I'm saying doing
this thing growing up PlayStation
recognize it they suck PlayStation I
need to find this game PlayStation I
need to find this fee I'll put y'all on
to the game I ain't know about the game
until y'all looking at my time now I'm
gonna say it I'm going to say I need to
find this because I was on the front
live hard I had them on IP I know y'all
watch PlayStation I know I love y'all
know y'all did the right thing but the
salute to them Xboxes
um yeah other than that uh dragon easy
fire Stella Blade Fire God of War wow oh
my God that looks it looked amazing look
they killed that that was an absolutely
phenomenal if it shows it shows that
sometimes you know less is better yeah
less is better 24 seconds
That's it man so well I got that's what
I got for Domino's
I'm hungry I know it's a long show and I
saw Super Chat you're gonna do the poll
and then not quick we gotta we don't
have too many okay cool uh let me god I
really thought
awful Grim bones
just got home from church just wanted to
show love to the Lords on the Lord's day
got to work tonight I'll catch this on
Spotify you will have plenty to listen
to Sir oh you're gonna go through the
whole shift with this we're gonna get
you out of your job
simple back eleven thirty eight five
dollars in the building yeah I
appreciate you appreciate you then we
got awful Grim bones two dollar Super
Chat once again I forgot this I
appreciate y'all okay I'm out
no doubt never got hargit to me ten
dollar Super Chat Jim crying dance moves
snitching lion Rhymes oh damn foreign
numbers man Square losing money he ain't
biting Phil will he needs jrpgs and Game
Pass good deal for uh SC shareholders
we'll see what happens
now yeah yeah this is a lot of money in
those bags that we got the Rising Sun
Phil just told Square I like [ __ ] and I
won't
now we do this the easy way or the hard
way the choice is y'all we just taking
it that's what we do it so romance just
taking it damn
Jesus
guy question King Phil vs Jim in a
boxing ring who wins and how break it
down for us take care of that dog
all right um
Phil came from the bottom up you know
Jim just you know popped up as a you
know
guys
you got to look at uh Phil as a little
mac
you understand
he definitely Gonna Knock Out Mike Tyson
at the end of this game oh
and I I think uh Jim is glass Joe oh
damn
I'm Gonna Keep it a buck if you're
telling me if if they have to do a real
scrap look at them yeah bill look like
he hit that gym for real yeah
Tokyo game show he was he had someone in
there someone in the chat said Jim will
cry to the judge yo
I think you punched an eye he bit me
to the point do the point King he bit me
and his hand got me
oh man that's crazy that's how they
point you out in the movie theater when
you're talking too loud
then we got a C wubby you five dollars
to attack Microsoft likes them big oh
yeah that's right like some rounds oh
like some chunky Xbox don't want none
unless you got ABK son oh
do we think there's still a PlayStation
showcase this year I mean possibly or
the bigger announcements go to Jeff at
game awards
I think we saw the big announcement that
was it yeah I think that was fun yeah
that's what we needed yeah
all caught up oh cut up all right Paul
let's get out of here with the recent
departures at 343 as reported by Lords
of gaming make sure you get on that
channel go subscribe go check out our
amazing writers how confident are you
that the Halo franchise could turn
itself around moving forward the choices
are eight after the disasters of Master
Chief Collection Halo infinite lack of
content for a flagship title I am not
optimistic on how 343 has handled the
franchise B now I have renewed faith in
the 343 recent changes for the long-term
commitment to Halo or C I don't care
because I'm not trying to hear nothing
until that Battle Royale drop but Halo
infinite those are the choices please
Rock the vote when it goes up again
salute to the Lords of dip down gaming
doing the entire Marathon I gave him a
chance to leave they get better days
like nobody rocking the whole thing dip
down games dip down anime please
telephon people where they can find you
and what you got going on sirs yeah man
dip down anime go ahead and hit
subscribe YouTube uh right now we're
running through that the cyberpunk edge
Runner yeah right now fire yeah I got
the dip down games going where we do a
lot of horror games things like that uh
do we do a live show every Thursday
night around 9 30 Eastern Standard Time
okay and then you know we're on Twitter
we're on Instagram down down games in
the building KP any words you want to
say get your bars off too for the crew
oh yeah you can catch me on Xbox double
K24 or you want to run some war zone
you know I like to shoot them things oh
we busted them things we want no smoke
he said you don't want no smoke for dip
down you don't want none whoa
you can catch me on Twitter that's uh K
double five oh okay double five let's go
at K double five make sure y'all go
support these brothers man doing their
thing and again salute to the amazing
lady Amber love what you're doing next
time hopefully we get you in the realm
of the Lord said yeah support them doing
anything out here and do it having a
good time having fun playing these games
you already know shout out some of you
soon chat let me see what it says but
send it over time check Australia's
awake yeah
sir
put me on Twitter Hey Lord addict IOP
definitely follow me on there for my
nonsense 24 7 7 days a week uh you can
also find me on uh YouTube gaming addict
uh you can follow me on Twitch at Lord
addict IOP I think I'm gonna start
streaming on there I got too much time
on my hands man like I don't I don't
know why I want to like fill the time I
shouldn't want to but like I don't like
I don't like having time to think if
that makes sense uh so you can find me
on there yeah definitely uh go over
there and follow me it was a good show
we had like man like uh almost 700
people in here uh you know definitely
hit that like button at your way out you
know we we would definitely hold you
hostage yeah
assistant
yeah yeah and then play you know I I
will be talking to the Lords about uh
what we're doing I've been trying to
apply for the fortnite uh Support
Program thing where we can host our own
servers but it's it keeps saying it's
down for sir I don't know what their
problem is but you know if I'm able to
get in there you know hopefully next
week we'll be able to do some Fortnight
and me and King can uh down a few of you
I'm just gonna take you out
[Laughter]
oh my God I'm sorry you left there wide
open oh yeah
you already know Lord song with five
people find you what you got going on uh
yeah I'm back to normal so they can find
me going to work immediately
[Music]
unfortunately but yeah shout out to the
crew at dip down you gotta love what you
guys are doing and again and the same
advice that we got you know when we were
starting out just keep doing what you're
doing be genuine be passionate and
you're just gonna you're gonna keep
seeing the people gravitate to you man
so love what you guys are doing just
keep it up just keep it a pleasure to
have you here thank you thank you you
already know Lord King where can I find
people find what you got going on this
this is the first time we had dudes on
like a reach across the road
first of all I thought that was dope but
the wildest thing is
it looked like they're in separate
places
[Laughter]
so he put his camera off and walked to
the bathroom
I go I was like yeah
I think that's good
um I didn't even know I I followed you
guys so that's how tight you know the
circles are you know that we we follow
um I'm gonna definitely look more into
the content but your history was
fantastic yes I do love it um you got a
A Very chilled nature and and and
finesse King over there
networking
I was networking but
um I love the history and I'm like I
said I'm gonna get into the content See
the content leave some comments and
stuff like that and definitely dig into
the content because when you know Cod
was like uh we having y'all on this week
I said I was like backed up with a whole
bunch of stuff so I definitely uh
definitely gonna give you all the watch
and a look and I definitely subscribed
so no doubt you saw me pop up you're
gonna see me all over the place oh yeah
appreciate it and yeah put your YouTube
link in your Twitter bio just a word of
advice from people trying to help you
yeah
um
let me put the um Twitter Link in the
joint real quick again just make sure
y'all go like And subscribe y'all out
here getting started doing their thing
you know what I'm saying attic and I um
already talked to uh Suave already okay
about some stuff uh new merch is coming
oh merch is going out of that store so
if you see something you like you better
get in there because it might be gone
when you go back there and check the the
next day also attic and I is putting the
finishing touches on a new program that
we're going to introduce that program is
going to be coming to you guys on Monday
and it's going to be very lit it's going
to be attic and I while and out
um attic and iron Unchained
yeah
like post on only fans
I think I think our content could rival
a lot of people anyway
wow find me on Twitter King David OTW
while I'm out here roasting foods and
having a great time doing such
um and I saw somebody I got to give a
shout out to this dude uh who decided to
make himself part of the podcast
I love I love the Ingenuity I love the
spirit behind it I love everything you
did it was fantastic it's all fun and
his jokes and nobody takes it serious
you don't have to go out there and you
know degrade the dude he put a lot of
effort into what he was putting up um
that looked like it took at least two
hours of him editing and putting the
stuff in and it was lighthearted and he
tagged Us in it because he's a fan and
he wanted us to see it so um shout out
to you I don't know what your name is
but you know us and I do apprec
appreciate you going through all the
hard work to try to be part of what we
do God Bless yeah we need a dedicated
person man you want a job
I'm like whatever bro don't go clip that
listen man look we outside it is what it
is my mission is different from what
other people doing that's whatever you
know salute to everybody that's doing
their thing you know what my mission is
my mission is to bring people together
to learn about these games give people
opportunity you know what I'm saying do
something positive space and also talk
to the creators these are the legends
you know what I'm saying the people that
give us these experiences stuff like
that so me personally I don't have time
for all that other that's cog's Mission
my mission to see the world
I can multitask let me assure you I can
multitask I was doing that right now
putting Twitter hands on it I'll try to
change people's life man my mission
I ain't trying to change my life that
way you relax just like just like that
you relax yourself you relax yourself
look it's all about Positive Vibes for
the kids
but what I will inspire you to do is
Health as well for getting that gym do
what you got to do you know what I'm
saying GG you know I'll be out here
moving and shaking that powder all you
have to do is do some powder
you get in the gym oh and you yourself
could be up for two hours I really want
to be a part of something come holla at
the kid and I'll help you you know what
I'm saying that's what a lot of it is
just people you ain't got to steal yeah
and I help you out because a lot of
times
before they put you in the car put your
head down in this case it was respectful
you know what I'm saying so it is what
it is but yo that's all I got Yo
Everybody Must Love hit that like button
on the way out do what we got to do see
y'all next Sunday it's gonna be super
lit unless y'all got anything hopefully
it ain't this long yeah and uh I'm
sending you guys to uh uh to to streamer
man go in there and tell them IOP sent
you you already know going over the
phones right now yeah go over there
won't let me send it to him for some
reason because he gotta he gotta put you
in the thing all right no doubt yo we
out
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]